what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Batman rebirth and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of all
this you'll have a good idea of where
the series stands and how it expects to
shape up going into the future of DC
Comics so much like Green Arrow and the
rest of the rebirth releases Batman
draws on a combination of pulling the
past and the present together however
the difficulty of this concept comes in
the idea that DC has never been
straightforward about Bruce's past
events in relation to the new 52 what I
mean here is that where the rest of DC's
lineup largely received clean cut
reboots Batman's past continuity was
left ambiguous with occasional
references here and there including
Batman eternal which saw the return of
Thomas Eliot who referenced a pre
flashpoint story hush while Barbara
Gordon discussed her recovery after
being shot during the pre flashpoint
story Killing Joke to this end while
this did offer the potential to maintain
the canonicity of some of Batman's most
iconic stories including nightfall on
the whole the reader was left in a
quagmire being expected to believe that
everything from crisis on Infinite
Earths to flashpoint all happened in a
five-year window while not actually
being told whether it did now where much
of the confusion fell to the wayside in
the face of scott Snyder's run with the
introduction of the court of owls and
the return of the Joker during death of
the family and ingame as part of
Snyder's multi-part epic the fact
remains that even if fans weren't
beating down the doors of DC for answers
at the very least some measure of
cohesiveness was expected to be
forthcoming if for no other reason than
to add death to Bruce Wayne's life
experiences but while fans look to the
idea of rebirth as a way for DC to
provide the answers they were looking
for instead the readers walked away
empty-handed being left with a multitude
of unanswered questions and a bit of
confusion written by Tom King and Scott
Snyder one of the biggest drawbacks of
the issue is that we don't actually know
whose hand is in the cookie jar
while the book feels almost exactly like
something Snyder would write Tom Keens
name is still listed as co-writer
leaving us to ask whether or not the
book is an actual representation of what
to expect going forward into the series
but initially opening up with Alfred in
the midst of tending the garden Wayne
Manor is visited by the arrival of Duke
Thomas in response to a previously
extended
offer to sidetrack for a second do
Thomas was one of several heroes
introduced as part of the we are Robin
line of comics under the banner of DCU
written by Libre Mayo and drawn by Rob
Haynes and Carrie Randolph while it only
spanned 12 issues the story focused on
Duke Thomas along with a handful of
other teenagers all of whom adopted the
mantle of Robin and operated as
vigilantes after being inspired by
various members of the bat family
receiving fairly high reviews but
experiencing mediocre sales like many of
DC's titles we are Robin was cancelled
between the announcement of DC rebirth
and the lead up to its launch at the
beginning of June
however focusing on the story the events
contained within center are kind of
truer Bruce Wayne's life as it
progresses throughout the length of a
week meeting with Lucius Fox on a
Tuesday the conversation between the two
is not of stupendous importance instead
it follows a standard method of Snyder
storytelling providing a bit of mortar
between the bricks of Batman's events
giving us some insight into his own
personal life to this end with Lucius
Fox recounting a conversation with
Bruce's father on why Thomas Wayne
became a doctor where Lucius founded a
bit foolhardy and the definition of
insanity by helping the sick while
knowing they would only get sick again
the rhetorical question is designed to
highlight the necessity of Bruce Wayne
being Batman and that while the
criminals he catches always escape
creating an endless cat-and-mouse game
the cycle exists because it needs to if
for no other reason than to keep
criminals from achieving their goal and
Gotham falling into disarray following
this the story transitions to Wednesday
with Bruce Wayne revealing to Duke that
Gotham has been met with the return of
calendar man a being whose life changes
with the seasons meaning he dies in the
winter is reborn in the spring and ages
through the summer and fall with the
cycle repeating itself now where this is
really just background stuff with Snyder
and King giving us something to read
while we make our way through the comic
the overall theme here is that Duke
continues to stay along for the ride
bringing him to the Batcave the purpose
behind Dukes presence is revealed with
Batman providing a home form in the wake
of his parents insanity to sidetrack
here during the events of Batman endgame
and Joker's attack on Gotham with the
Joker intending to reenact the death of
Bruce Wayne's parents by using the
parents of Duke the toxin Hughes had
permeated their minds
seeing them into insanity without an
immediate cure where Bruce was able to
rescue Duke and escape Dukes parents
were left behind leaving Duke himself as
an orphan using this as a jumping-off
platform while neither King nor
Schneider offer direct answer the
implication seems to be that Duke is
being offered a position alongside
Batman that is akin to the Robin mantle
but remains ambiguous with Duke
appearing receptive to the idea this
revelation is really the only standout
part of the story in truth things
essentially fall back into rank and file
with Batman coming to the realization
the calendar man had planted spores
around Gotham which if released will
kill everyone in the city now as far as
I'm aware there's no real explanation
available about these spores and it
seems to be designed that way what I
mean here is that because this rebirth
issue appears to be written in the form
of a week in the life of Bruce Wayne a
place on the notion of every comic being
an end of Gotham scenario and the idea
that Batman is the only one who can save
the day
well the story does see Batman
succeeding and destroying calendar man's
machines as well as depicting his
rebirth in the form of shedding his old
body and emerging as a younger person
the events shift their focus to a
conversation between Batman and Duke
with Bruce revealing that where Duke is
concerned about calendar man returning
and constantly thinking of new ideas
their roles as heroes is to meet the
challenge and comeback themselves
equally more intelligent and capable and
so with the story wrapping itself up
this seems to reveal the shortcoming of
the issue nothing really happens the
comic makes no reference to Snyder's
Batman aside from Dukes parents during
the events of endgame it makes no
reference to the supposed death of Bruce
Wayne after in-game and Commissioner
Gordon taking on the mantle of Batman
and as far as I can tell the entire
issue treats the events of DC U as if
they never happened picking up almost
immediately after the Joker's perceived
death at the conclusion of endgame with
Bruce Wayne taking Duke on as award
so as we continue our discussion on DC
rebirth for those of you guys that had a
chance to see my episode of collecting
coffee on Sunday the we had talked about
how with Hickman's Fantastic Four and
with those various videos being ongoing
stories in the background of my regular
videos then I was kind of experimenting
with you guys I was looking to see how
you guys would be receptive to having
double videos almost every day and
having stories in the background of our
existing content on you know character
discussions and different things like
that and so what I want to do is I want
to start paying a little more attention
to DC simply because it really didn't
make any sense to change from Marvel
explained to Comics explained if I'm not
gonna give DC some due diligence and to
be honest I'm really just now getting
around to reading a lot of the DC
rebirth content
but I'm absolutely loving Batman and so
what I want to do is basically run over
this story I guess the entirety the
entire six-part series Batman
I am Gotham we're gonna do one video
over the course of this week or I guess
one issue over the course of this week
so you guys will get the full brunt of
the experience and decide for yourselves
whether or not you know Batman from DC
we birth is something that you're
interested in picking up but I am Gotham
of course is the official start of
Batman rebirth in DC Comics under the
writing of Tom King now one of the big
differences here is in the Batman
rebirth number one issue that was
basically kind of giving us a status quo
and what it was telling us is that Duke
Thomas a character who appeared as part
of Snyder's run on Batman who was the
leader of the vigilante group calling
themselves Robins that he's basically
been taken under the wing of Batman as
the new Robin and so at this point he
basically had several Robins of course
the first was Dick Grayson the second
was Jason Todd the third was I think
Stephanie I'm sorry was Carrie Kelly
followed by Stephanie Brown and then I
think we got into Tim Drake but I'm like
I'm not gonna swear that I'm correct
about that chronology well Duke Thomas
comes to us as the newest Robin and so
this basically gives us a chance to see
how Batman is relating to him now
what we do here is we initially pick up
in a flight now in terms of the people
in this flight they're not extremely
important for this first issue but it
does give us some context right now we
basically have Bruce Wayne and we have
Commissioner Gordon talking to one
another they're talking about how there
was a raid on Fort Marshall but that
somebody had basically taken off with a
handful of
rockets somebody had taken off with with
weapons and the question was what what
are they gonna do with them what's the
big plan here but even then they're not
really talking to you heavily about it
and so it's just kind of like okay what
what direction are things really going
in here because Town Tom Kane Rob sorry
Tim King is basically playing the the
very slow road here he's playing the the
very slow game so to speak but in the
middle of their conversation Batman and
Commissioner Gordon witnessed the plane
being blown up after a rocket seemingly
hits it from behind and so what we do of
course we pick up with Bruce Wayne
immediately taking off and he's talking
to dude and what he says is I'm sorry
he's talking to Alfred and what he says
is he needs a plan to basically figure
out what's going on with this plane and
that's the basis behind in this
particular comic this whole first issue
is showing us the lengths that Batman's
goes to and this is one of the reasons
why this is so cool
is because Tom King doesn't leave us
hanging Tom King doesn't suddenly just
jump from one scenario to the other he
takes us through every single step of
the way and so one of the first things
he does his Batman sends out an SOS to
the Justice League specifically to
Superman and - Hal Jordan because it
would make sense to us as the reader
that if a plane was crashing to the
ground in Gotham City that Superman
would get there in seconds in moments
he'd be able to save the plane and
everything would be fine if he wasn't
able to do it Hal Jordan might be able
to get there a little bit slower but
he'd get there pretty fast and he'd be
able to use his power ring to save the
plane but what tom kean is basically
telling us here is that or I guess he's
providing an answer to all those
individuals who asked the question if
Batman encountered a scenario where it
seems insurmountable that he can come
out on top why doesn't he contact the
Justice League and the response that out
for it gives Batman is that nobody in
the Justice League is picking up they're
all busy off doing their own things
they're fighting their own villains or
dealing with their own own individual
problems and they're just not available
to help Batman and so this allows us to
continue on with this line of thought
that Bruce Wayne is gonna have to be the
one to save this save this plane and so
what he does is he starts talking to
Duke and this again is really cool
because this is not something that we
see very often with Duke and Batman
conversing what Duke says is that there
is a time frame here that the plane is I
guess that Batman have selves will have
to drive in about a hundred 22 miles per
hour that he will have to hit a hit of
ramp so to speak or hit a bridge at a
certain angle
and then he'll have to take off and
you'll have to jump from the the
Batmobile and you'll have to land on top
of the plane and so they're basically
just working out exactly how this is
going to happen and again this is really
cool because usually even with Scott's
letters Batman as great as it was
usually he simply just jumps from one
scenario to the other and the extent of
detective work comes in the sense of
Batman analyzing some little detail but
we don't really see them going over the
mathematical angles and all this really
does is show us how smart Bruce Wayne is
the Bruce Wayne isn't stantly just a guy
that can put clues together Bruce Wayne
is a guy who has you know mathematic
probabilities statistics rattle around
in his head and he's able to calculate
those incredibly fast with the
assistance of Duke and so what we do
here is we pick up with Batman jetting I
guess jetting out of the out of the
Batmobile and landing on top of the
plane and this is actually pretty
awesome because he's talking to
Commissioner Gordon then Commissioner
Gordon again is basically driving under
this plane trying to get to where it's
going to land into the best of
everybody's estimates including Batman
himself that it's going to land in the
the try corner yards and Batman's idea
is to keep this from happening and the
reason why is because if it did there
are crowds of people there and the the
loss of life would be insane if they all
died and so what Batman's trying to do
is he's trying to get the plane to land
in the Gulf of Blackgate in a giant body
of water that way the only individuals
who who will be in any real measure of
jeopardy are those on the plane and of
course the goal of Batman is to mitigate
as much of that as much loss of life as
possible and so from this point it's
really just Batman flying onto the plane
landing on to it attaching you know
different pieces of machinery attempting
I guess attaching a little Jets and so
on and so forth and the goal is to
basically steer the plane in a direction
toward will pass through two buildings
and to effectively guide it even though
it can't be controlled by conventional
means now from where here we transition
to the inside of a plane and this is one
of the reasons why I think this thing is
so cool because with Batman comics we
largely just focus on Bruce Wayne the
only real view that we get outside of
his own perception of what's going on is
usually from a villain like a villain is
watching events unfold or Commissioner
Gordon is watching events unfold and we
see their perspective but we don't
really get the perspective of average
people of your average joes and so what
happens
really just this guy who's just freaking
out I mean the plane is crashing the
guys you know terrified rightfully so
and he's basically saying like they're
in Gotham City all they have is Batman
you know it'd be better if they landed
in Metropolis cuz Superman would have
saved them instantly it'd be better if
they landed and you know Coast City
because how Jordan would have saved them
you know or Jessica Cruz or you know any
number of other factors you know Simon
bass for example probably could have
saved them you know but they're in
Gotham City there's a man that flies
over you know that the glides around is
a bat what can he possibly do because
he's just a regular guy at the same time
he thinks that you know he starts saying
things like maybe they deserve it
because they're they live in a city full
of criminals that have gone absolutely
insane and so this isn't really design
to point to some greater picture this is
it really designed to point to some
great big huge concept but somebody to
show that different people react to
situations differently and this just
kind of gives us a bigger understanding
or a better understanding of how regular
Joe's deal with life and death in the
face of Batman doing what he can to
basically save their lives and so the
result here is that while Batman is
attaching various artifacts what he does
is he starts talking to dude and this is
one of the one of the ways in which the
Batman story really starts to get cool
this is one of the reasons why I think
Tom King is doing such a great job
writing Bruce Wayne's perception begins
to shift away from complete confidence
in the fact that they're going to be
able to save the people on this plane to
the possibility that he might die and
the way that this happens is as Alfred
is talking to Bruce Wayne and as Bruce
Wayne is talking to Alfred what he says
is or I guess what he asks is what his
parents be proud now this is basically
just kind of Bruce Wayne accepting his
fate this is Bruce Wayne accepting the
fact that he may not live here now of
course we we switched to a scenario
whereby somebody is watching or standing
over the body of another individual and
this person seems to seem to have been
the one that shot the rocket that shot
the plane down
and this person is dead we don't really
know who this individual is that's
watching him the but the result is that
we switch back to you know about Anne's
conversations with Alfred and Batman's
basically kind of
getting his affairs in order you know he
tells Alfred that if he doesn't make it
that on the off chance that he didn't
survive or that some event happened that
would have killed him he prepared a
guide so to speak you know a few words
of wisdom for those individuals who were
closest to him the members of the bat
family and Alfred himself and he
instructs Alfred to pass those those
little bits of information on to those
members of the bat family but he also
says that if something happens to him
that Duke should go train under the
direction of Dick Grayson just because
of the fact that Dick Grayson is as good
of a teacher as Batman will be now this
gives us perception of how Bruce Wayne
views Dick Grayson we've always known
that Batman viewed Dick Grayson with the
utmost respect even though they've had
their falling-out even though they've
had their disagreements you know they
haven't always seen eye to eye
he was the first sidekick and he spent
the most time alongside Bruce Wayne as
Robin and over the course of dick
Grayson's life he's even played the role
of Batman you know a time or two and the
result is that he is as good of a Batman
as Bruce Wayne will ever be and this is
really just Bruce Wayne confirming it
and the comics we've seen this before
you know but this is DC rebirth this is
basically you know DC giving us a
perception of what to expect going
forward and so the you know Tommy king
is effectively telling us it's not as
though with DC rebirth all that history
and all that you know importance all
that you know the the relationship
between Batman and Dick Grayson has just
kind of gone away instead it's just as
strong as it ever was
and so as they are as his plane is
appears to crash into the ground just
before it hits or crashing of the water
rather just before it hits the plane is
lifted up from the water and Batman's
initial thought is that it's Clark that
Superman has come to the rescue but
instead he's greeted by two individuals
the man addresses himself as Gotham and
the woman addresses her I guess he tells
Batman
this woman is Gotham girl that this is
their city and that they're here to save
it so as we pick up with part two of
Batman with DC rebirth I was scrolling
through the comments of the last video
and somebody to ask the question what
happened to the new 52 Batman and this
is kind of an indication to me that not
everybody is aware of what went on with
Batman in the new 52 and so what I want
to do is take I guess the first part of
this video to kind of clear this up
to make things easy to understand with
its character because Batman can be a
bit confusing when it comes to the new
52 so as we know in 2011 DC rebooted
everything the new 52 was a line wide
reboot whether you loved it or hate it
that's that's what we got and what DC
originally established was that it has
only been 5 years between the time that
superheroes first emerged and the start
of the new 52 now with regards to DC
rebirth the only thing we really know
right now is that it was actually 10
years that were stolen from people's
lives and that was all done supposedly
at dr. Manhattan but again this is a
very primitive story we have no real
idea of what direction DC is going in
with that and so that's that's really
the only thing we know I can't really
offer you any more info besides that but
virtually everybody in DC Comics got a
reboot the Teen Titans were rebooted you
know Superman was rebooted Wonder Woman
Aquaman the whole nine yards the only
two characters who were not rebooted was
the Green Lantern and Batman and that
was simply because of the fact that the
comics were selling so well
they didn't make any sense to reboot him
it was a classic adage if it works don't
fix it and so with the character of
Batman what DC did is they came back and
they retold his origin story we got that
in Batman zero year and it told us what
was going on in the life of Bruce Wayne
from the time his parents died up until
the time he became Batman when Batman
issue number one came out with a new 52
the issue with this is there was no
explanation on his backstory there was
no ever I guess no not really his
backstory there was no explanation about
all the stories that had happened before
he was you know before the new 52 we
didn't know if stories like hush had
actually happened we didn't know his
stories like nightfall if The Killing
Joke if things like that had actually
happened in the new 52 instead DC just
left it open-ended and they're still
doing that what DC says is none of the
stories that happened in Batman's
history before the new 52 actually
happened unless they say they did and so
during Batman eternal for example we saw
the villain hush returned and DC
established that the storyline hush did
happen in the new 52 we had reference to
the Killing Joke in the story of Barbara
Gordon Batgirl zone line of comics and
so we know that Killing Joke happened
and we had actually seen reference to
the events of nightfall when Bane broke
Batman's back and that was referenced
what DC is basically telling us is that
whenever they reference a story from the
for from before the new 52 dev store
happened in the five-year window and so
this Batman that we're seeing right now
is the pre new 52 Batman
it's just DC's kind of left it open as
to whether or not the stories have
happened before the new 52 actually took
place I know it's a little confusing
it's a little weird not really sure why
they chose to do that but the best rule
of thumb to take here is that unless an
event like nightfall is referenced
unless an event like hush or like The
Killing Joke is referenced it's best to
assume it just doesn't happen I know it
kind of boggles the mind in terms of
like all that stuff happened over the
course of five years but you know it's
you got to kind of go with it for what
it is you know it's it's comics don't
think about it too hard you'll make your
head explode that's that's how I live my
life when it comes to college but the
fact remains that now that were painting
that with issue number two in the last
video we basically just talked about how
Batman was in Gotham City it says normal
rare and wear-and-tear where he's saving
the city of course Duke Thomas is the
new Robin to take the place of Damian
Wayne at least at the moment anyway and
and what's basically happening right now
is we're continuing the event of the
arrival of two characters that came at
the end of the last video the first one
referencing himself as Gotham and the
second one being Gotham girl and so what
we do is we pick up with kind of with
with solomon grundy basically if those
of you guys who don't know solomon
grundy is i wouldn't go as far as to say
he's DC's Incredible Hulk just because
of the fact that he predates Incredible
Hulk as far as I'm aware but he is one
of the strongest characters in the DC
Universe and he's a very intimidating
foe but he always has a mantra that goes
along with him and anybody this read DC
Comics and is familiar with solomon
grundy knows that mantra of course a
mantra being born on a monday christened
on the tuesday married on a wednesday
took ill on a thursday grew worse on
friday died on saturday buried on Sunday
that's his thing and so while this is
happening while solomon grundy is
basically tearing a part of this statue
in gotham city gotham girl and n gotham
are both trying to defend it as best
they can they're trying to I guess stave
off Solomon Grundy and what this is
designed to do what Tom King is
basically showing us is two things the
first is that Batman isn't necessarily
against them being there but the second
is that they're very inexperienced and
we would expect this you know Batman has
fought solomon grundy on a multitude of
occasions and so one he knows the best
way to deal with him he knows the best
way to interact with him and he knows
his weaknesses
Gotham in Gotham girl they don't know
this all they know is that solomon
grundy is just a bad guy who's trying to
tear things up and so what ends up
happening here is of course Batman
subdue solomon grundy by using his
momentum against him now this is
actually one of the funny things I was
having this conversation with a friend
of mine and he had read Batman edition
number two and his thought was that
Batman had actually picked up solomon
grundy and of course the answer to that
is absolutely not
Solomon Grundy's way too heavy for
Batman to lift this is someone just an
example where Solomon Grundy's running a
Batman Batman uses the momentum and
flips him over on the ground but of
course the solomon grundy is also
someone that doesn't necessarily fear
Batman but even if it's on a base level
understands that Batman's not a guy to
be trifled with
and so what Batman does is once he
hasn't pinned down of course he says
that that your solomon grundy gets up
it's going to hurt a whole lot more now
this is where the inexperience of Gotham
and Gotham girl come into play this is
where Tom King tells us Batman isn't
really against them being there of
course what Batman says is that they
were wasting too much time that in
Batman's mind it's all a matter of
calculations it's all a matter of
figuring things out as all a matter of
knowing what's going to happen within a
reasonable time frame then he tells them
that because they had wasted so much
time because solomon grundy was moving
so fast
if batman had not intervened it would
have resulted in the death of a homeless
man at least we presume he's homeless
um but we would have resulted in the
death of this man and so what Batman
says is he's been watching them but
they've been doing the best they can to
keep Gotham City safe and this makes
sense Niki's Batman wouldn't simply
allow just two people to show up in
Gotham and start acting in a superhero
fashion without keeping an eye on them
even if he doesn't necessarily intervene
he would definitely be aware of what's
going on and that's what's happened here
Batman's been watching them and he
simply says they're doing good they're
doing some very good things but the goal
is to do better now he doesn't give them
an actual idea of what to do on how to
do better and this is kind of a funny
thing with Batman because unless you
were Robin Batman doesn't really you
know take you under his wing and teach
you everything step by step with Robin
of course he does that because the
Batman's mind Robin is designed to be
his successor one day Tim Drake Dick
Grayson Stephanie Brown Carrie Kelly
Damian Wayne they're all designed to be
successors or at least they were trained
to be successors for Batman they all
went off on their own individual story
arcs and of course as we know Dick
Grayson went on to become a Nightwing
Tim great Tim Drake I believe went on to
be read
but we know that they've taken on their
own identities but if the worst case
scenario happened and that man died any
one of them would be able to take up the
mantle in his place especially someone
like Dick Grayson but the issue here is
that with Gotham and Gotham girl not
being given a clear understanding of
what it is that they're supposed to do
they asked for it you know Gotham simply
says if we're not doing what it is that
we need to do in order to be effective
superheroes for the city of Gotham then
tell us what we need to do tell us how
to be you know crime fighters tell us
how to fight intelligently as opposed to
just kind of being you know a broadsword
swinging through the city of Gotham had
bad guys and so what we do is we
transition later and we pick up with
Bruce Wayne when he is you know
monitoring various footage radagast
certain forms of footage that he has on
Gotham and Gotham girl and in his mind
it's kind of a tough situation and
because he has largely been the sole
protector of Gotham for quite some time
he's had sidekicks he's had people that
helped him but when it came down to it
we as readers always look to Batman as
the sole savior of Gotham City but to
have two superheroes here who are for
all intents and purposes more or less a
version of Superman they may not
necessarily be as strong but they fly
they have you know super hearing and I
guess ultra hearing you know they have a
you know incredible vision and so on and
so forth they have all the feats of
Superman you know to a lesser degree and
of a different name it's kind of a
situation of is Batman really even
useful here anymore if the time comes
when they are trained to the epitome of
what it means to be a superhero the time
comes when they are as good as Batman in
terms of being able to analyze the
situation then being able to neutralize
that situation then of what use would
Batman be it would be as if Superman
showed up in Gotham City and said he was
going to start protecting it but at the
same time he also realizes that
sometimes he just needs help that with
the incident of the plane that with the
various asteroids and things like that
with all the different threats that had
faced Gotham City if they were beyond
Batman's normal ability to take care of
that Gotham and Gotham girl had done it
they had basically you know they had
saved the plane they you know you I
guess diverted asteroid so on and so
forth they were doing the things that
Bruce Wayne couldn't do and in his mind
it's a struggle because he's facing he's
looking at these two and he's basically
seeing the fact that he's becoming
obsolete he's seeing a Gotham City that
no longer needs him
this is one of the reasons why tom kean
riding is so cool because we don't
really see this very often we see
stories where Batman goes against
overwhelming odds but we don't really
see stories where Batman sits down and
has to ponder the fact that he could be
obsolete the fact that he wouldn't
really matter anymore obsolescence I'm
not really sure that's order now but I'm
going to use it as a word I'm going to
make it one if it's not but anyway
without ffred showing up outfit of
course you know Brees us back to earth
he brings us back to you know the
everyday life of Batman that's one of
the great things about Alfred and the
story is he always keeps us anchored to
the present and he basically tells us
that in Wayne Manor
there was about 250 guests who were all
there to see Bruce Wayne for a you know
a Children's Hospital gala that they put
together and this is just you know of
course we don't really see Bruce Bruce
Wayne go often do you know performing
that gala cuz we don't really need to
instead Tom Kean deviates our attention
to building another plot building an
upcoming set of events and what he tells
us is that with Commissioner Gordon
working over you know staying over for
about two or three hours to do whatever
it is that he does in the Gotham City
Police Department that there is
apparently a man who is down there
waiting for him and when this man comes
up to meet me Commissioner Gordon now
what he says is that he is the person
that sent solomon grundy free now our
initial thought or at least my initial
thought when I first heard this was that
maybe this guy was just some kind of you
know villain mastermind that with him
drawing some kind of a blade that he was
actually going to kill Commissioner
Gordon uh I would have found that hard
to believe this early in Tom King's run
but that was my initial thought is
that's what he was entertaining to do
instead he doesn't tell us that the what
he tells us is that his name is Bob
Castro that he served in the military
but the reason why he said solomon
grundy free was because of Solomon
Grundy's extreme strength and that he
had been warned that the monster men are
coming now we don't get anything more
than this from this guy Bob Castro and
the reason why is because Bob takes the
knife and he stabs himself in the neck
with it and kills himself now this is
really kind of cool here because in a
lot of Batman's stories we usually have
like the one you know the exposition the
one point where the guy comes in and
says here's everything you need to know
about events that are coming up instead
Tom King doesn't do that he's very Zak
sir I'm sorry he's very Scott Schneider
in that way then the sense that he's
kind of building up to a major plot
thread and we just sort of have to read
things in order to understand
what all's going on but what we treat
what we do here is we transition back to
Bruce Wayne at the gala and Bruce Wayne
receives the bat-signal
and so while he is spending time with
what appears to be a very attractive
woman he basically takes off he leaves
and the result is that he ends up having
somewhat of a conversation with Duke
Duke of course you know carries on the
conversation a bit with Alfred but in
the end he says that because of the
bat-signal because of everything that's
going on that he basically needs to
leave now this is one of the other cool
things too is he gives us some insight
in how he views Gotham and Gotham girl
we as readers know that Bruce Wayne has
a very hard time trusting anybody in
fact he trusts nobody and even says that
that he doesn't trust Alfred now this is
a lie we know that Bruce Wayne trust
Alfred with his life in fact is you know
Alfred's been such a long part of Bruce
Wayne's history that unless you're
reading all-star Batman you have no
reason to distrust Alfred I'm not going
to spoil that at the moment if you
haven't read all star Batman
you definitely need to go check it out
but the fact remains here that you know
Bruce Wayne says that he does not trust
Gotham and Gotham girl now it doesn't
mean that he thinks they're bad it's
simply that he's waiting to see what
goes on he's playing it smart he's
playing the long game
and this is this is a hallmark of Bruce
Wayne he always does that whenever he
encounters anybody new he always plays a
long game he always waits to see what's
going on to see what their motives are
before he really begins to extend any
measure of trust of them in fact we've
been seeing that with Superman with the
pre new 52 Superman living in the new 52
continuity during the son of Superman
story that I went over the Bruce Wayne
says flat out that they don't know him
they don't know that version of Superman
they know the other version of Superman
who died they fought alongside him but
they don't know this pre new 52 Superman
and so they don't really have a reason
to trust him but they will so because of
the fact that he has done everything he
can to prove that he's legitimate guy
much like this with Gotham girl and
Gotham you know when they show up at the
bat-signal Jim Gordon is initially
afraid he's like what in the world is
going on here you're not Bruce Wayne
you're not Batman and Batman simply says
don't worry about it they're with him
and so what is up happening is Jim
Gordon basically tells them what all's
taking place you know what all is
happening that there was a man who
showed
that you know killed himself after he
claimed that there that the monster men
were coming and he initially asked
Gotham and Gotham girl do they know
anything that's been going on strange
anything that would indicate that you
know there is a there are some kind of
enemy force that are showing up in
Gotham City
now of course Gotham and Gotham girls
say no and and Batman says no he doesn't
know either but they all sort of
reference the the instance where the
rocket was shot at the plane and the
person who had shot that rocket had also
committed suicide and so what this seems
to indicate is that perhaps there's a
series of events that are unfolding this
indicates that maybe all these
individuals work for the monster men but
in some form or fashion they seem to be
tied in to the concept of the monster
man and they ended up committing acts in
their own name now what's really cool
about this too and these what we're
gonna see what the end of the story is
if I were to hazard a guess and of
course you know not spoiling anything
you know just sort of live in the moment
to sort of live in right now if I were
to hazard a guess I would say well maybe
it's because of the fact that all these
individuals are these these people are
part of a larger plan they've been
assigned tasks and they're carrying
these tasks out but whatever the case
may be in the end that man basically
bails out without any of them knowing
this is such what's really cool and
again this kind of points to the
inexperience of Gotham and Gotham girl
you know Commissioner Gordon is used to
Batman just vanishing up in smoke just
disappearing and going off to do his own
thing Gotham and Gotham girl are not
used to this not only that despite their
abilities they can't find Batman
anywhere now the Wii U's comic book
readers know that this was most likely
due to the fact that Batman has honed
his skills in such a way that he can
avoid Superman if he wanted to but the
fact remains here that with him
vanishing this is just kind of Batman
being Batman is not really designed to
be an extremely important moment it's
just designed to be something a little
funny something a little interesting you
know - for us to get a bit of a laugh
out of but the fact remains that what we
do here is we switch to another location
oh we initially pick up with a guy who's
not really named and this man is simply
just answering questions he's shown
images of his face where he's scared
where he's happy he's sad and he's angry
and he's being asked are you scared are
you happy are you sad and are you angry
and each time he replies yes professor
and what we learned is that he's
actually talking to professor Hugo
Strange now this is not the biggest part
the biggest you know kind of
the story reveal here is that Hugo
Strange seems to be working in
accordance with the United States
government and Amanda Waller of The
Suicide Squad and so this is just one of
those instances were the plot thickens
where things become a lot more
complicated and so what we'll do is
we'll find out in the next video of
course where this line of thought is
leading us to and yeah it's pretty cool
so far like the story is actually pretty
interesting so as we continue our
discussion on Batman rebirth but we pick
up now with I am Gotham part 3 now when
it comes to multi-part story arcs
they're usually three issues or more and
there's a reason for that
odd numbers are more often chosen than
even numbers but you know with DC they
tend to stick with six issue story arcs
but regardless of the circumstances
everything's done in sets of three the
first two issues are done to sort of set
up the story the second I'm sorry the
third and fourth issues are designed to
effectively enhance or to add existing
information and the fifth and sixth
issues are designed to conclude
everything and with issue number three
Tom King begins the process of reviewing
the backstory of Gotham and Gotham girl
what we do is we pick up at some point
and the relative past not too far but at
some point in the past again we're not
given a definitive date here and we just
know that it was probably a decade or so
but during a time when a family was
basically leaving a theater
this was very indicative of Bruce
Wayne's experience and in fact when I
first picked up the story I thought that
it was a retelling of Bruce Wayne's
origin which seemed a little strange
because the boy was older than Bruce
Wayne was when his parents were killed
but much like that scenario this family
is heading down an alleyway why they
chose to head down a dark alleyway I
don't understand but they chose to head
down an alleyway in the midst of walking
down this alleyway the most you know
predictable scenario happens and they're
held at gunpoint now where the father
steps in and tries to protect both his
wife and his son the man is basically
subdued the father is almost immediately
subdued and the result is of the gun
again has turned to the mother and
eventually the son but Batman steps in
here and Batman basically saves the life
of this family now for Bruce Wayne this
is a big deal because this is
effectively a repeat of the scenario in
which he lost his parents and this kind
of situation resonates
more with Bruce Wayne than any other
kind of situation despite the things
that the Joker does that Clayface to
face the penguin so on and so forth
they're usually part of a bigger scheme
in the county book realm they're part of
a bigger ongoing set of events in in
Gotham City but things like this that
depict a family being held at gunpoint
in the same fashion as Bruce Wayne's
family when its parents died this
strikes a chord and Bruce Wayne
immediately lashes out but for Batman
this is also a chance for him to be the
person that wasn't there when his family
died and this is what he does you know
as this husband and wife and son as
they're basically consoling one another
having survived the encounter Batman
tells them that it's okay to be scared
they're going to be scared for quite
some time that everybody gets scared for
one reason or another but the important
thing is to learn from that fear to
learn to fight fear and to go forward a
stronger person now of course what we
know is that this young boy was
basically Gotham and the young girl
presumably his sister who we'll find out
here in a little bit is Gotham girl now
the connection between Gotham and Gotham
girl and the events that we just went
over is revealed to us when we switched
to Robinson Ville and Gotham City now
with regards to Gotham as a whole this
is one of the big myths no MERS Gotham
is largely considered to be a singular
place in and of itself Gotham City does
have suburbs but it's still considered
to be heart of Gotham in and of itself
and so what we find is that the parents
who had been held at gunpoint are
meeting with a man from the Federal
Bureau of Investigation and what they're
telling us is that after the incident
whereby they had been held at gunpoint
that the boy named Hank had basically
become obsessed with Batman to a degree
the word that Tom Kane chooses to use
here is enamour'd but the evidence seems
to contradict that the evidence says
otherwise
with all the various news clippings and
all the posters and all the pinups and
so on and so forth it seems as though
Hank has developed an obsession with
Batman as a concept in addition to this
while his younger sister was not present
at the robbery because she was at a
friend's house in the end the experience
that Hank had basically rolled over onto
her and as she sort of became just as
obsessed as he did with the idea of
overcoming her own personal fears now
Tom Kings being a little thin here with
regards to you know the relationship
between a brother and
sir in terms of how one's experiences
impact the other we could really just
kind of take it at face value that in
some former fashion he had basically
reached out to her and he had informed
her of her experience or I guess of his
experience and how it changed his life
but the fact remains that his sister
Claire became just as obsessed as he did
or it seems to become an assess as Hank
did with regards to Batman and so this
basically shaped his life and it shaped
her life that Hank began going around
and committing as many you know good
deeds as he possibly could volunteering
different things like that
that he began weight training he began
exercising pushing his body to the peak
of a physical experience that that both
Clara and himself began to experiment
with you no forensic evidence began to
read about you know science as much as
they possibly could and this is really
just designed to say that instead of
them you know having some sort of guide
to take them through their own
experiences instead they followed the
exact same road as Bruce Wayne that
Bruce Wayne taught himself a lot of the
things that he knew he also traveled
around the world to gain a lot of these
experiences but he taught himself a lot
of the things that he knew and the
result is that he is he proved himself
to be a formidable combatant and take on
the Batman mantle and full force much
like Bruce Wayne Hank and Claire have
done the exact same thing and in fact
light Bruce Wayne traveling around the
world they did the same they won't ever
cease they did you know some work in
some very dangerous areas and this went
towards expanding their view of the
world but also how harsh humanity can be
and how important it is to stand up for
what's right to do the right thing in
virtually any circumstance now the
connection between pink and you know
Claire with regards to why they're being
questioned or why their parents are
being questioned by the FBI comes into
focus when Tom Kane shifts the argument
and what he does is he begins adding the
FBI agent asked questions about money
transfers now this is not usually
something this handle by the FBI this is
usually handled by the IRS so it's a
little fishy but the fact remains here
that if there's criminal issues involved
well then the FBI
would begin to involve themselves in the
events and so at the very least the FBI
is kind of poking around and asking the
question why there's two new superheroes
in Gotham and where they came from
but what the parents of hanging Clair
say is that at some point while they
were overseas they got a request to wire
a large amount of money no reason was
given but because they were their
parents and they were concerned for
their well-being but also because Hank
and Claire had been extremely charitable
people on how they live their lives
there didn't really seem to be any
concern that anything nefarious was
happening and so they transferred the
money and then I guess a few months
later Hank and Claire appeared in Gotham
City as heroes who effectively had the
same power as Superman now again miss
FBI agents is kind of poking around or
at least a person claiming to be an FBI
agent it's just kind of poking around
trying to get a lay of the land and
trying to understand everything that's
going on but the end result here is that
we're getting somewhat of a mysterious
backstory we're not getting all the
information and so before anything else
is revealed the FBI agent effectively
leaves and as he gets into his car we
realized that he's using the alias of
matches Malone which is also a name that
Bruce Wayne uses and so in effect
Batman's poking around at the history of
these two individuals trying to find out
where they came from now in truth I
wasn't really expecting this I actually
thought that it was probably some kind
of a henchman of a villain or something
along those lines but this makes sense
this makes perfect sense you know with
Batman basically doing his research kind
of hunting around behind the scenes it
would stand to reason that he would go
as far as to look up the heritage of
these two people and to find out where
they came from but it also gives a
little bit of perception when it comes
to Bruce Wayne as we talked about in the
last video Bruce is not a very trusting
person when it when it comes to anybody
to be quite frank of course the vehicle
that he was driving was not an actual
car instead it was basically a housing
for his for his bat motorcycle I'm not
sure exactly what it's called you know
the bat wheel I guess I can't remember
but is basically you notice that this is
just a multi-faceted depiction of the
deception the lengths that Bruce Wayne
will go to to get the information he
needs it doesn't necessarily make him a
bad person it's just that at times it's
necessary for him to be duplicitous in
order to gain honest answers and so what
we do is we switch to Clair and Hank who
are in the middle of old
a bridge that seems to have collapsed
and while Batman is racing and trying to
get over there in order to keep things
you know in order in order to both
monitor Hank and Claire to make sure
they're being heroes effectively as well
as do what he can to ensure the safety
of those bystanders we also see that
while he is able to do this that the
entire situation is being monitored by
Hugo Strange now as we talked about in
previous video Hugo Strange is a well
known you know villain of the Batman
landscape but he usually uses his
experience or his knowledge for the
purpose of manipulating other people but
he's really one of these villains as
kind of the hidden hand you know it's
usually a circumstance just like this
where it turns out that he co strange
was behind everything and so while the
bridge is saved
I guess the bystanders on the bridge are
saved the old wall things seem to come
to a close eventually Claire and Hank
are met by the arrival of psycho-pirate
a villain capable of manipulating the
emotions of virtually anybody he comes
into contact with and so the question
becomes what direction are things taking
now so as we continue our discussion on
Batman rebirth what we do here is pick
up now with the aftermath of
psycho-pirate seemingly causing Gotham
to go insane and for those of you guys
who are just now joining us in this
series who may have just stumbled across
this video DC rebirth is a line of
comics written by DC designed to
basically take what worked before the
new 52 and blend it with the new 52 and
with characters like Batman he's kind of
a weird quagmire of course we talked
about this in the in the last video but
Batman didn't really get a reboot per se
in the new 52 instead it was just kind
of up in the air whether or not his
continuity had stayed intact and we were
just sort of left to our own devices you
know stories like hush like nightfall
like The Killing Joke they weren't
considered part of Batman's continuity
and the new 52 unless they were
referenced and so we didn't really get
any solid ground we were really just
kind of walking on quicksand when it
came to his backstory but the fact
remains that as part of DC rebirth
writer Tom King had introduced two new
characters
the first was Gotham and the second was
Gotham girl now in the series up to this
point they had basically saved the plane
that was preparing to crash into a river
and Batman was trying to keep the plane
protected trying to keep the plane from
crashing but ultimately he was
unsuccessful and he was even facing his
own death
the process but because Gotham and
Gotham girl seem to have powers that
made them almost identical to Superman
and Supergirl they were able to save the
plane and by virtue of that save you
know however many hundreds of people now
but what the series had done up to this
point it is it basically given us a view
of Batman in terms of how he sees Gotham
and Gotham girl and in his mind he had
done a little bit of back search you
know a little bit of investigation into
their history we saw that in last video
where he had gone to talk to their
parents and it had been Batman himself
who had inspired them we didn't know
exactly how they became Gotham and
Gotham girl but we know that Hank was in
a situation much like grill you know
Bruce Wayne's parents were by Hank and
his parents were walking out of a
theater they head down a dark alleyway
they were held at gunpoint but Batman
showed up and saved the day after that
Hank had become obsessed with Batman and
his obsession had spread to his sister
Claire and the result was that the two
of them had basically become great
humans you know great people they had
gone on humanitarian missions they had
done as much research as they could with
forensics they had basically become
their own variations of Bruce Wayne and
the result was that after some set
amount of time that wasn't really given
to us you know they had borrowed money
from their parents and then they had
really manned gotham girl with
superhuman powers and so what this does
is it picks up again with the last issue
where the villains psycho-pirate had
showed up under the control of dr. Hugo
Strange and had used his powers to
seemingly drive Gotham insane now to say
this psycho pirate has powers is
actually a misnomer now probably
shouldn't have said that psycho pirate
to the best of my knowledge and this is
where you know Tom Kings not absolutely
clear here psycho power can be a bit
confusing in the new 52 he was infected
with the virus giving him you know some
measure of psycho I guess you know
psionic mind abilities by Brainiac but
in the pre new 52 continuity he was just
a guy who was really good at
manipulating people's emotions um you
know Tom keen doesn't really give us any
definitive explanation on which
psycho-pirate that we're talking about
you know it could very well be that it
is the you know pre new 52 or it could
be the new 52 it could be one version
wearing the costume of the other we
don't really know all we do know is that
he manipulated the emotions of Gotham
and this is shown to us when Gotham had
gone on a tear and basically killed 27
soldiers now his sister Claire is left
behind and she just keeps repeating the
same things that she's scared that she's
very scared and of course this is a
byproduct of psycho Pyrus manipulations
once he
latches on to a person once he latches
on to a being regardless of who that
being is and where they hail from in the
multiverse once he manipulates their
emotions that manipulation stays intact
unless someone with sufficient ability
is able to remove those manipulations
now of course that man being what he is
there's been different circumstances
where he's been successful in doing it
and where he hasn't been successful in
doing it it really just kind of calls
for what the story needs it to be but
what is up happening is we show up right
as we transition to to the rooftop of
another building and we find a guy who's
standing on the building and seems to be
in the process of committing suicide now
the Gotham shows up behind this guy and
and basically you know it seems as
though he's going to talk him down but
Gotham keeps repeating the same thing I
can fix this we can fix this it's the
same thing being said over and over and
over again but the guy says no the guy
says that no this cannot be fixed that
the monster men are coming and this is
this is a weird situation here because
what we're gonna find at the end of the
story is that not everything is what it
seems when it comes to the realm of the
monster men but the result is that this
man has some kind of a device on his
phone
and when he presses the button to
activate it it blows up the building now
this seems I guess has revealed to us to
basically be a flashback in the mind of
Claire and this tells us exactly what
was happening right before psycho-pirate
showed up with Hugo Strange and
manipulated Gotham and so in yesterday's
video when we had simply just picked up
with Gotham and Gotham girl in a
building that was you know immersed in
flame we didn't really know exactly what
was going on this is we just tells us
that but what we do know is that Claire
had been taken back to the Batcave
presumably at the request of Batman
where she's being cared for by both
Alfred and Duke Thomas now this is kind
of a funny thing here and I really like
what Tom King was doing with this with
Duke Thomas and one of the things that
I've kind of missed spoken about so far
in the series is that Duke Thomas was
supposed to be a Robin which is sort of
ironic because I covered this in Batman
in my Batman rebirth video Duke Thomas
is not actually supposed to be a Robin
that was a mistake that I made in the
previous videos Duke Thomas is a
character they're just being groomed to
be someone presumably taking the place
of Batman that seems to be the common
idea here
I don't recall whether or not Batman had
actually stated that and in Batman
rebirth I'm pretty sure he did I think
you just said we said that Duke was
being groomed for something else but the
overall theme here is that Batman
especially with the events that had
transpired this far and the ion
awesome series you know Bruce Wayne is
coming to the conclusion that with
everything that's happened up to this
point with quarter vowels night of
vowels with the return of Joker in death
of the family Batman in game the Bruce
Wayne's kind of coming to grips with his
own mortality that it seems as though
he's basically losing his grip on Gotham
City itself and the result is that
someone needs to be able to step up and
take his place and even if that's not
the case
Bruce Wayne also recognizes that he's
not immortal he's not gonna live forever
you know he is going to die at some
point Anton then even if Dick Grayson is
a great superhero he still got Bludhaven
to take care of neo Damian Wayne is
forming the Teen Titans
you know Tim Drake is off doing his own
thing basically every member of the bat
family has their own situation to take
care of but Duke doesn't have that Duke
was introduced during Scott Snyder's run
of Batman he is a character who led the
you know the we are Robin team he's
basically kind of groomed himself to a
degree to be the new Batman and then
Bruce Wayne's just sort of taking the
next step and giving him the official
training so to speak but what's
interesting about this is that Duke
basically relates to Claire again she
keeps repeating the same thing that
she's scared that she's scared and it's
kind of funny that that dude doesn't
really pick up on this but in his mind
this is really just a girl that's
experienced a very traumatic event but
what Tom King also does here is he seems
to set up a possible romance between
Claire and Duke Thomas basically having
Duke Thomas you know comfort Claire as
best you can and then presumably this
may or may not lead to a relationship
the reason why I say that is because in
comics it's usually some kind of
traumatic event that leads to a
relationship between two characters
either that or just they kind of start
out as enemies like you know like Green
Arrow and black Canary did and then they
become you know they and they end up in
a relationship later on down the line
but it's their trials and tribulations
that strengthen that relationship of
course and again this could just be
wishful thinking because I love the
character of Duke Thomas and do Thomas
needs a girl so I figure what better you
know care do to have than a newly turned
superhero basically you know add to the
existing bat family as someone that can
fight alongside Duke Thomas and so what
we do is we transition back to Gotham
and you know Gotham is again continuing
this rampage talking about how he can
fix things and it's just sort of tearing
you know doing things apart but Bruce
Wayne shows up Batman shows up and says
look everything you've done up to this
point you killed 27 soldiers no you
cannot fix the
you know but what Bruce Wayne also does
is he gives us his official view he
gives us an official exposition on what
he thinks about Gotham this is cool
because it's something that we haven't
seen before we've seen him poking around
we've seen him doing investigating but
this is basically the conclusion that he
came to when he first met Gotham
you know Gotham and Gotham girl had
saved that plane from crashing into the
river and Batman realized that they can
do things that he can't
they're basically Gotham City's own
Superman he had looked to them as
possibly the next step and what Tom
Kings seemed to be doing or at least in
my mind anyway as I was reading this is
if Duke Thomas is being groomed for a
replacement for Bruce Wayne then Bruce
Wayne himself looked at Gotham and
Gotham girl as you know kind of attacked
on addition to that an unexpected you
know an unexpected way for him to
basically bolster the continuation of
the bat family they kind of continue the
legacy going forward but the result is
that Batman says that despite the fact
that he looked at both Gotham and Gotham
girl ask people that could have saved
Gotham City in a way that he couldn't in
the end
Gotham killed 27 people and it basically
seems as though he is officially a
villain or in some former fashion a
villain that's that has ulterior motives
or simply just lost his mind became
drunk with power now one thing to point
out here is that Batman does not know
about psycho pirate and Hugo Strange in
the equation in his mind he simply just
stumbled onto a circumstance where 27
people were killed the word I am Gotham
was written in blood and so Batman
simply went by the evidence that existed
at hand but once he and Gotham begin to
get into an argument once they begin to
you know to discuss it I guess you know
debate with one another ah what dozen
happening is of course Gotham takes off
after this joining the Batmobile and
Duke chimes in to Batman stating that
he's found a pattern you know among
these soldiers that were killed and what
he says is that their dog tags when the
numbers are rearranged when the numbers
are you know when the when the pattern
is discovered the number comes out to be
24 and what is up happening as Batman
puts two and two together and realizes
that you know this basically adds up to
Task Force X now the way this ties into
Task Force X is actually really really
cool and this is one of the things that
I like about Tom King because he
basically expands on the clandestine
nature of the Suicide Squad but he's
also or at least also seems to be
leading up to the Justice League versus
Suicide Squad event which would be the
first major crossover of the DC rebirth
line of
comics but what he says or what Duke
says is that after cracking the code he
came to realize that the unit in
particular that was killed was the 24th
unit of a military you know military
group and the 24th letter of the
alphabet is X and so what Batman ends up
doing here is coming to the realization
that X stands for Task Force X which is
the other name that's the official name
for the Suicide Squad and so what he
ends up doing is he basically travels to
where Amanda Waller at least we travel
to where Amanda Waller is located and
she's essentially talking to a military
general now what's really cool about
this is you know Amanda Waller in this
bunker and this military base of thereat
is actually below Gotham City itself and
it's the last place we would expect to
find her to be quite honest you know
with Amanda Waller in the new 52 we
would have expected to see her in the
field but this is what's so cool about
DC rebirth is that it gives us the old
Amanda Waller that we're used to before
the new 52 and so she's the office
worker but she is cold blooded I like to
think of her as the mob boss of the DC
Universe in the sense that she's a
person you don't cross you know she
knows all the right people she's like
the j edgar Hoover
you know she's got info on everybody and
those individuals that she wants to stay
in power stay in power and those that
she doesn't want to stay in power do not
stay in power and so while she's talking
to this military general the guy says
that it's impossible for Batman to find
them you know that they are you know
miles below the surface of Gotham City
Batman will never think to look for them
in Gotham City he's got soldiers he's
got huge military-grade doors that
Batman can't penetrate but all of that's
wrong and the reason why is because
Batman is there Batman managed that way
to make his way and now we're not told
how Batman got in there and in truth we
don't really need to be told right now
someone because of the fact that it just
adds to the to the cool aspect of Batman
it adds to the fact that Batman can go
where he wants when he wants how he
wants and there really isn't anybody
that can stop him plus it just kind of
adds to the mysterious nature you know
of the Caped Crusader as we know him but
you know after he begins talking to
Amanda Waller we learned that from her
perspective the Gotham City has been a
very tumultuous place for quite some
time and again this is basically you
know DC grabbing a combination of the
new 52 and the pre new 52 continuities
again with that man it's a little
finicky here but you know what we're
told is that after you know the court of
owls event the night of owls
now the Batman in game the return to the
Joker you know death of the family all
these different events are to take place
taking place it it basically sent Gotham
into a tailspin of chaos and what seemed
to be destruction and the result is that
for Amanda Waller's point of view this
city basically needs to be saved the
issue here is that when Hugo Strange and
when psycho-pirate had been assigned to
Task Force X you know as part of Suicide
Squad they hit abandon their mission and
they had basically taken to Gotham City
and that psycho hired himself had
manipulated the emotions of of Gotham
and sent him down a direction of
insanity Amanda Waller had sent those
military personnel to try to corral
psycho-pirate and he goes strange back
in you know back you back to the Suicide
Squad but because they're villains and
they do what they do they ended up
having Gotham killed those soldiers
anyway now it just seems as though what
Hugo Strange a psycho pirate want to do
is just bring down Gotham City they just
want to instill a whole bunch of
violence you know chaos different things
like that but the result is that Amanda
Waller turns to Batman and essentially
says that he's going to help her bring
down Hugo Strange and cyber pirates and
well because of the fact that one Batman
wants the city saved and to Amanda
Waller will not abide people who abandon
their role in The Suicide Squad she will
have them killed if it comes to that and
so what's also really funny about this
this is one of the things that I really
love about the pre new 52 Amanda Waller
is she simply says that she's only going
to help Batman do this if Batman says
please and this is what's so cool about
this because Amanda Waller is literally
telling Batman like you have to ask me
to help you you know not because
formalities but because I just feel like
seeing you beg and that's what's so cool
about this is because you don't screw
with Amanda Waller and and it's just
it's super cool you ask any DC fan you
know about Amanda Waller and they'll
tell you by leaps and bounds that number
one it's the Amanda Waller from the
Justice League TV show that was the best
one that justice Lucar TV show that was
the best version of her character but to
you know the pre new 52 Amanda Waller in
the comics was probably the best
depiction of course she doesn't have
fans for the new 52 and it really kind
of goes back and forth but you know what
we also learned is that where Batman
believed that it was 28 pure I'm sorry
27 people who had been killed Amanda
Waller actually says was 28 and this is
when Batman realizes everything that's
going on or at least realizes you know
there's a little more going on here that
he thought there was and he ends up
traveling back to the home of Hank again
we had talked about that in a last video
when Batman had gone to interview Hanks
parents to find out who he was where he
came from what his background was and
what his motivation was for becoming a
hero and what we find is that when
Gotham had gone through and killed those
27 soldiers that there was actually 28
but one of those soldiers had survived
and had gone back to the home of Gotham
and had basically killed Hanks parents
and so when Hank realized what was going
on he went back to his home as well and
found this soldier in the middle of you
know his parents murder and the result
is that you know Hank is basically
freaking out he's losing his mind and
Batman tries to talk him down Batman
tries to says no you can still turn back
you can still stop this you can still
set things back to normal
but Hank basically throws Batman's words
back at him and says no you cannot fix
this you can only make it worse and
instead he kills the soldier cast Batman
aside and then takes off with the
intention of destroying Gotham City now
again we're still you know we're a
couple issues away from the conclusion
of this story so we don't really know
the bigger picture here at the moment we
don't know if there is a much bigger
role that he goes strange and
psycho-pirate are playing here we simply
don't know if they just want to destroy
things we don't really know everything
that's happening but what we do know is
that this is going to lead to a pretty
significant battle so as we continue our
series on Batman rebirth we pick up now
with Batman I am Gotham the conclusion
now something that I want to point out
here is there is a sixth issue and that
sixth issue does have an epilogue but
the issue here is this epilogue leads
directly into I am suicide and so what
we'll do is we're actually going to
postpone that sixth issue and when we
get around to the I am suicide story arc
then we'll use that six issue to kind of
jump off because what it'll do is it'll
allow us to link both this I am Gotham
story and the I am suicide story for the
new readers who are coming along at that
point in time but for those of the guys
who were just now jumping on board who
were just now catching up with my video
on Batman I am Gotham we talked about
how in previous videos Gotham City was
met with two new Hugh two new
superheroes calling themselves Gotham
and Gotham girl now we didn't really
know who these heroes were or
where they came from we know that Batman
was trying to keep a plane from crashing
into the river he was doing the best he
could to keep that from happening but in
the end Gotham and Gotham girl were the
ones that basically saved the plane and
so from Bruce Wayne's perspective he
didn't initially trust them but because
his I guess their first impression on
him was that they were acting as heroes
he decided to let them continue without
challenging them and basically learn
more about him and this is what he did
he actually went to their home and once
he figured out who they were and began
digging into their history and what he
learned was that when Hank was a child
the name of the guy Gotham a hank had
basically encountered that man when Hank
and his parents were held at gunpoint by
a robber in the same fashion that Bruce
Wayne lost his parents and seeing what
was going on Batman had intervened and
he had basically saved the life of Hank
and his parents but because of this Hank
had become obsessed with Batman now
something to point out here is that
Bruce Wayne's interaction with Hank
wasn't necessarily long it was simply
that Bruce had said that the paint that
what he was feeling at the moment was
was fear and that it was okay to be
scared and because everybody gets scared
but the difference between being a hero
and being a coward is that heroes deal
with their fear they come to grips with
their fear and so Bruce Wayne had
basically inspired Hank and Hank himself
had recited this mantra over and over
again that is okay to be scared but he
should always face your fear and had
used this mantra to both inspire his
sister Claire to join him on a journey
of bettering themselves and this was
done in a multitude of different ways uh
Hank and Claire had you know basically
trained themselves in physical combat
Hank and Claire had expanded their minds
when it came to forensic science they
had traveled the world to become
volunteers in a different I guess a
multitude of different facets they
basically that are taken the same kind
of self training regimen that Bruce
Wayne had taken when he became Batman
and so the result was that during this
time they had reached out to their
parents for a large sum of money and for
reasons unknown or through a means that
we didn't fully understand it was never
really explained to us they emerged some
months later with superpowers now while
we're still not told exactly where those
powers came from in this issue what we
are told is exactly how it works then
what happened is that in the last issue
because of the fact that Gotham had
manipulated by psycho-pirate a villain
that had the power to manipulate the
emotions of people the psycho-pirate had
basically screwed with Gotham's mind and
ended up putting him in a situation
whereby he had an irrational hatred for
Gotham this was August Gotham City this
was compounded by the fact that one of
the guards one of the soldiers that
Gotham had killed had gone back to the
home of Gotham and murdered his parents
and so because of this this these
manipulations sort of fed in on
themselves to where Gotham had a hatred
of the city and then he had a hatred of
the people in the city because one of
them killed his parents he didn't
realize that he was the cause of his own
problem and so the result here was that
he began travelling back to Gotham City
in order to lay waste to it and Batman
had intended to stop this but because of
the fact that Gotham had fought Batman
directly the Batmobile was destroyed and
Bruce Wayne was left several miles
outside of the city without an immediate
means of return and so what he does is
he asks Alfred to basically intervene on
his behalf to buy some time now of
course personal he doesn't actually
expect Alfred to fight as Batman just
because of the fact that Alfred does not
have the combat skills to pull that off
but he is successful in buying time he
approaches Gotham and claims to be
Batman
but because Gotham has various powers he
immediately seized this Bluff but in the
time between when Alfred was bluffing
and when Gotham calls it Batman shows up
and so Alfred takes off and heads back
to the Batcave and Batman and Gotham end
up in a battle that basically stretches
across the city of Gotham now Batman
tries to reason with Hank here he tries
to tell him tries to talk him down say
hey look Randy can't be tear it here in
the city up we can solve this emotional
crisis that you're having but Gotham is
so entrenched in his anger and so
entrenched in his rage that he just
can't let it go now during this time
because of the fact that Gotham had
killed those soldiers his sister Clara
basically watched the events unfold now
Tom King is not specific here when
Claire was when Claire was found by
Bruce Wayne she was basically just kind
of sitting in the corner in a fetal
position basically saying that she was
scared the reason why I say that Tom
King isn't really clear on this is
because we don't know if if her fear was
a byproduct of you know cyclop Harris
manipulations or if it was because
Gotham was kind of her backbone he was
the the guy you know the brother that
kept her grounded and kept her confident
and strong but the result is that while
Gotham girl was taken back to the
Batcave and put under the care of both
Duke Thomas and Alfred she's watching
the events unfold both on the news and
through various you know camera devices
the Batman has around Gotham City and so
in the midst of this conflict because
Gotham City's being laid waste to in
such a capacity Duke tries to reason
with her you know Duke tries to talk to
her but she doesn't really want to do
any of that she doesn't really want to
talk to anybody and so what Batman says
is with everything being as chaotic as
it is because of the fact that he cannot
handle Gotham on his own he tells Alfred
to get ahold of the Justice League and
that's exactly what happens in the
intervening moments when things are kind
of going chaotic when Batman's holding
off Gotham as best as he can the Justice
League shows up here of course we have
the pre new 52 Superman we have Wonder
Woman we have Barry Allen we have
Jessica Cruz and Simon Baz the Green
Lanterns of Earth and cyborg and Aquaman
now what's really interesting about this
situation is the Justice League is a
formidable force in and of themselves I
mean they're really the the cream of the
crop when it comes to DC's earthbound
superhero team and of course with
regards to Superman sometimes Wonder
Woman and especially Simon Baz and
Jessica Cruz you know some heroes who
operate beyond the planet Earth who have
the potential to operate beyond the
planet Earth we would expect them to
easily be able to subdue Gotham but this
is not the case Gotham not only power
overpowers a Justice League he
overpowers Superman now this is
important because it's this this is
basically Tom King telling us how
powerful Gotham is in the new 52 the new
52 Superman that we saw when the you
know reboot first launched was weaker
than his pre new 52 counterpart but when
the new 52 Superman was killed and the
pre new 52 Superman took his place we
saw the stronger of the two Superman
emerging this Superman that we see here
is the pre new 52 Superman he's the
strongest version of Superman
you know in the post-crisis on Infinite
Earths continuity and Gotham is easily
able to overpower him now we didn't
initially know what the basis behind
this
it was simply because his powers were
just that much more advanced or if there
was something else going on but this
explanation is given to us by virtue of
Claire of Gotham girl herself and what
she says is that they basically bought
their powers now again we're not given
you know an explanation on where these
powers came from in this story or where
they bought them from we're simply just
told that they bought them and that the
powers they bought were super-strength
you know invulnerability ultravision but
the use of these powers and the limit of
their powers was relative to their life
and what I mean here is they basically
sacrificed years of their life for
higher levels of power and so there was
no limit to how how strong they could be
there was no limit to how strong Gotham
girl or Gotham could be there was no
limit to their invulnerability there was
no limit to you know how well they could
see to their ultra vision but the higher
they took their powers the more years of
their life they would lose and so if
they wanted to be an ordinary citizen
they could live for decades if they
wanted to be like Superman they would
have to sacrifice a few years of their
life but if they wanted to be godly in
terms of powers they would only have a
few hours to live and so what ended up
happening here is Gotham has basically
pushed his powers to the brink he has
pushed his powers to the extreme to
where they're at their highest levels or
seemed to be of the highest levels that
his life can withstand to the point that
he has maybe minutes
you know half an hour something like
that left to live and so what Claire
says is that because his power is so
extreme he seems effectively unstoppable
and there really doesn't seem to be a
way to beat him and his goal is to
effectively destroy Gotham City
and so what Batman does is he steps up
here and offers himself to Gotham and
saying that you know that psycho-pirate
was allowed to you know commit his acts
because he hadn't been killed by Batman
that autumns parents were killed because
Batman didn't get there in time and so
he's basically mating making himself the
victim here Batman would rather Gotham
kill him
did wipe out Gotham City at the same
time were given a little bit of a
narrative between Claire and Duke & Duke
says that you know Batman's mantra is
always it's okay to be afraid but you
have to face your fear now this strikes
a chord and Claire because from her
perspective this was not a quote that
you heard from Batman it was a quote she
heard from her brother Hank
who of course got it from Batman and so
this is again basically you know
clearing up the the discussion earlier
about how we said where Tom King wasn't
really clear about you know Gotham girls
saying that she was scared this seems to
indicate that Gotham was kind of her
backbone he was her foundation for the
confidence that she had and the result
was that this was rooted in the idea
that Hank would constantly comfort her
in saying it's okay to be afraid but you
have to face your fear the result is
that once she learns that this was
basically Batman that Batman was the one
that had inspired her to become a
superhero by virtue of inspiring Hank
she immediately takes off to confront
her brother and so for a fraction of a
moment in order to basically keep from
killing herself
Gotham girl puts her powers to the
extreme and in the process of doing so
ends up killing her brother and that
effectively wraps up the story you know
that that sort of brings things to an
end to be honest with the guys this is
kind of this this story was kind of
interesting to me um it really seemed
like Tom King was using this as a
platform to introduce a new superhero in
the form of Gotham girl uh you know I
enjoyed it for what it was I felt like
the the you know the the conspiracy of
the three Joker's really should have
been the first story arc to kind of
bring us in but it also feels like that
would be a trump card and just because
that's the one thing that a lot of
people are really looking forward to a
lot of people want to know about the
history of the three Joker's the
conspiracy of the three Joker's and
maybe it would have been introducing
that in the beginning would have just
been too soon you know maybe it was
something better suited for two or three
story arcs down the line which seems to
be what DC is going for all right so
continuing our discussions on DC rebirth
we pick up now with Iams suicide I kind
of Miss the old intro like so what I
want to do here is have a discussion
about I am suicide this is actually
really cool this this story is you know
Tom King and Hum King due date this
guy's kind of crazy um you know with
vision he it was crazy good with I am
Gotham it wasn't really hitting the mark
but I am suicide I'm impressed I mean
this is this is a good story this is
this is a really really solid story and
I think it really speaks volumes to the
way that he uses characters right
because in comic books there's all
different kinds of characters out there
and a lot of people use them in a lot of
different ways but the mark of a really
good storyteller is a person who could
use a character in a way that was just
never really you
before a way that maybe you know we
never really thought to use them before
and what I'm talking about here is
actually the relationship between
psycho-pirate and Bane and we'll
actually get to that here in a minute
but what this does is this gives us a
little bit of a rehash with regards to
Bane's origin story in DC rebirth now I
do have a video on the origin of Bane as
part of DC rebirth and you guys are
welcome to check that out you'll find a
link down in the description but again
it really just kind of refreshes us that
main basically spent a large majority of
his life and Santa Prisca prison he
escaped for a while but it also confirms
the events of nightfall in Batman's
continuity now this has been confirmed
already I mean Bane had already
reappeared I think it was part of Batman
eternal um I know that was hushed but I
actually never really read through
Batman eternal I'm just kind of going on
some of the videos that I think Betty
made but with Batman's continuity I
actually want to talk about this for a
second because a lot of people have
expressed confusion on where things
stand with Batman's continuity it can be
a bit confusing but so in the new 52
launch because remember the DC rebirth
event is basically still the new 52
continuity when new 52 launched Batman
got you know a retelling of his origin
in the form of really you know Batman
zero year but the question a lot of fans
had is if according to new 52 it's only
been five years since superheroes first
showed up on the scene then what does
that mean for Batman's history what does
it mean for events like nightfall and if
it's like death the death of the family
and The Killing Joke and all that kind
of stuff and DC basically said well
everything in the history of Batman
happened in five years is so it really
you know is strain credulity
um DC rebirth has actually come back and
said well it's actually ten years not
five but we still have yet to see how DC
rebirth will expand into the overall
larger DC continuity and how it's all
going to come together so again there's
a lot of questions that exist there and
there's a lot of things that still need
to be answered but at the very least
again this kind of reminds us that Bane
is a guy that did fight Batman he did
break his back during nightfall and so
the two of them do have history together
more so than that psycho-pirate is not
just a villain like that Ennis that's
why I say things are kind of cool here
now we don't know if this is Roger
Hayden or if this is Charles house Ted I
think it is um this is I was actually
talking to Sal and I was talking to Joel
about this and the weekly pull chat
because we were true I was trying to
figure it out I was like which one is it
is it you know DC's never really said
and it doesn't really matter in
particular I don't think but
historically speaking psycho pirates
always been a guy that had the ability
to manipulate the emotions of others
to basically make them feel certain
emotion so he can make a person feel
fear
he can make them feel anger you know
happiness sadness so on and so forth but
he was always a guy that did this for
you know his own particular crimes or
maybe he would go against some super
powerful being or something like that
and this story Tom Kane basically turns
him into a drug and it's really really
cool because Bane is literally just kind
of recounting you know going going back
in and more or less giving psycho-pirate
his backstory and talking about the pain
and torment that he feels over the
course of the failures that he's had in
his life you know when he was basically
forced to live and in Santa Prisca
because of his father's actions you know
when he was forced to experience the
death of his mother when he had been
defeated by Batman after defeating him
all these things you know all these
these experiences in his life has just
kind of sent him into an emotional
freefall and so he basically uses
psycho-pirate to make him feel better
you know he tells a psychopath
tell me that I'm happy you know tell me
that I'm brave tell me that I can always
stop and so instead of being addicted to
like venom you know the drug that
basically gave him super-strength and so
on it's really just him being addicted
to the emotional feelings that that
psycho pirate can engender inside of him
now from here we pick up with Gotham
girl because keep in mind throughout
most all of Tom King's run following the
events of iron Gotham where both Gotham
and Gotham girl were introduced as a
brother and sister superhero duo were
psycho-pirate had manipulated Gotham
into basically losing his mind and
becoming a bad guy and then eventually
it took the whole bat family to kill him
the O Gotham girl was manipulated to
feel extreme extreme fear and that's
never really gone away she's never
really gotten over that she's been able
to temporarily get past it but it was
very much like Jessica Cruz you know if
she was introduced she was just always
afraid she'd be able to get over that
fear but it was only for a temporary
amount of time it's only now in Sam
Humphreys Green Lanterns that she's
finally learning how to conquer her fear
especially after the events of Darkseid
war and she's able to actually become a
Green Lantern and start creating
constructs with Gotham guerrillas much
the same way the problem with this is
that because the influence of
psycho-pirate
is so strong Bruce Wayne comes to the
realization he basically says I've got
to go I've got to go and I've got to
find psycho-pirate I basically have to
go to Santa Prisca to the base of Bane
get psycho-pirate and bring him back the
problem is Batman can't do that on his
own
between Bane between psycho-pirate
between all the soldiers that they have
there there's no way that we'll be able
to pull this off by himself and so what
he needs is a team now this is where
things get cool because the story kind
of takes on this like Ocean's eleven
kind of feel to it not in the sense of
like you know the the goofy or the jokey
nature and like
thieving is someone and so forth but in
the sense that Batman is effectively
putting together a team so it's like you
know Batman's for I guess Batman's 11
it'd be kind of a cool that'd be a cool
story like Bruce Wayne's 11 like I would
I would breathe like Bruce Wayne he's
like we're gonna go rob casinos in Las
Vegas I would love that but the first
person that he picks up traveling to
Arkham Asylum its ventriloquist now this
guy Arnold Wesker is probably like he's
the queen on the transport he's the most
it's not really the most important but
the most powerful piece with regards to
the plan that they're gonna have going
on the reason why is is going to become
apparent as we get to the end of this
but Arnold Wesker is a guy that DC
really toys with the reason why the
whole relationship between like Woody
the puppet and the ventriloquist Arnold
Wesker was so cool and the reason why
he's always been kind of a mainstay as a
villain in DC's comics is because of the
fact that DC walked the line we always
kind of knew he had multiple personality
but there were some writers who wrote
stories about him where there were tires
where it seemed like Woody was real like
the puppet was actually real and Wesker
was just doing what the puppet wanted
him to do you know being able to give
the puppet life really changed
everything so because that had added a
whole new you know a whole bunch of
different effects more so than this some
of the other people that he picks up of
course is actually a girl named jewel a
guy named Braun Steiger and then another
guy named punch now of course bronze
tiger a lot of people are pretty
familiar with him the story as it's
given here is pretty self-explanatory he
more or less suffers from delusions of
grandeur but he's still a very capable
fighter not only that of course Batman's
like look you're a little faster than I
am I need you on my team for this
mission that we're gonna go on but Jewel
and punch are actually a little more
intriguing here of course with Batman
being accompanied by Commissioner Gordon
jewel is a girl who's basically been
stuck in a catatonic state now the
introduction of Jewel and punch actually
came out of the possible cancellation of
the Joker and a lot of people don't know
that back in the 1960s it was entirely
possible that because Batman's comics
just weren't selling and the Joker
wasn't doing well because of the college
code DC thought about like killing his
character off but what they needed was a
more tamed down version but still
entertaining equivalent of the Joker and
so in 1967 I think and I think it was a
Captain Atom comic they introduced Jewel
and punch now they were like the like
the Joker Harley Quinn they were like a
one two a one two punch combo when it
came to being silly and being
nonsensical of course it was like the
Joker and Harley Quinn about thirty
years before Harley Quinn but the fact
remains here that they were basically
nonsensical they were slapstick
jewel has these jewels that allow her to
use different abilities energy
projection manipulating emotions and so
on these guys have their own little
gadgets their own little tricks what we
learn here is that with jewel having
been in a catatonic state
the Commissioner Gordon is not
Commissioner Gordon instead Commissioner
Gordon is actually punch and what punch
had done is he had come to the
realization that if jewel was within
Arkham Asylum a time would come when
Batman would basically go to see her for
whatever reason for information or
something along those lines and when
that time came he was basically gonna be
at his side disguise s Commissioner
Gordon now of course Bruce Wayne picks
up on this almost immediately but
allowed to let you know ed lighted to go
through the reason why was because he
looked a punch at set is astounding the
lengths that you will go to go to to
rescue this woman that you care so much
about you literally tricked the entirety
of the Arkham staff you broke into an
insane asylum in order to rescue the
woman that you love and he says I need a
person that has skills like that now the
last person that we pick up with and
this is why when the story first
launched when I have suicide first
launched it was a huge deal because
everyone thought this was the Joker you
know the story initially started off or
I guess the this conversation initially
started off almost exactly like The
Killing Joke you know I've been thinking
lately about you and me that's how The
Killing Joke started off when Batman
first encounter the Joker in the story
the conversation that they had but as
you know Batman's talking to this person
and begins to undo the mask on their
face we learned that as Catwoman the
reason why she's here is because she
killed 237 people and we don't know why
now of course we actually figure that
out or at least we're told what it is
here in a second and the story behind
this is actually really kind of cool
what Catwoman says or at least the other
way it's given to us is kind of like in
a letter that she wrote to Bruce Wayne
as he's basically having all these guys
or at least he's invading Santa Prisca
mob it's really one of these situations
where cat will they compared herself to
Bruce Wayne in a lot of different ways
that as a girl who was raised in an
orphanage that was run by Thomas and
Martha Wayne she had seen you know the
picture of Bruce and Thomas and Martha
and it always imagined herself being a
part of him and that was always really
kind of a cool element of her character
is Catwoman always aspired for better
but always tried to achieve better in
the worst way possible but the kicker to
all this is that she essentially says
that her parents uh you know she never
really knew them you know never really
had a chance to meet with him instead
the orphanage the fire that was caused
was by some crazy terrorist group you
know and there were two hundred and
thirty seven of them and so what she did
is she started a Gotham City and she
literally went through and killed every
last one
and then she expanded outside of Gotham
City and eventually traveled the world
killing every single member of this
Harris group you know they came into
their act and they had no reason no
motivation there were no claims no
demands no nothing they just did it for
the sole purpose of inspiring fear now
that's why she's in Arkham Asylum and in
fact the next little bit of the story
will really focus on Batman in terms of
him originally catching her that part's
not extremely important it is kind of
interesting but we're gonna go ahead
actually leave that out of the story
just because of the fact that it's not
really a necessity for the main events
that are going on here but with Batman
arriving at Santa Prisca of course it's
it's 1:1 against 1,000 and despite how
capable he is I'm actually glad with
what Tom can get here because some
writers may have been tempted some
miters video may have been like yeah of
course it's ridiculously impossible but
Batman was somehow able to defeat 500
soldiers and it all happened off panel
Tom Kings like no no that's stupid like
that it'd be cool to see but there's no
way even even the most staunch of Batman
fans would just be like I mean I don't
know about that like I love Batman but
he's not gonna defeat 500 people with
automatic machine guns it's not gonna
happen and so of course Batman is
effectively taken prisoner now he's
brought before Bane himself and the
kicker about the about all Lister's
remember Bane is not using venom right
now so he's not using the substance that
allows him to take on this extreme
strength and in fact during his
conversation with Bruce Wayne with that
and he basically tells him that he's
like I'm not using venom right now so I
can't defeat you as easily as I did the
first time we met when I broke your back
at the Gotham City but he says I could
still break your back and that's exactly
what he does he breaks Batman's back and
so what he does is he basically takes
him dragging him down to the same prison
cell that Bane himself had spent so much
time in and then just kind of leaves
Batman there now of course Batman is
able to make his escape you know
becoming being what it is a Batman is
able to get out but once he does we
basically learned that you know Selina
Kyle the Catwoman had come along as part
of this plan and that she had personally
brought the ventriloquist the point of
Batman even be caught in the first place
was to basically be thrown in a prison
cell and then allow you know himself to
basically open a back door for Catwoman
and the ventriloquist to get in because
in his mind he knew that is intelligent
as Bane is you know in Bane's mind
Batman can't escape if that man's back
is broken he's not gonna be able to get
out and so if he's being held prisoner
there's really nothing Bruce Wayne can
do and so he can effectively just kind
of throw them in there and call it a day
now at this point we switch over to the
conversation that these guys are having
here
yeah this is really kind of cool because
what this does is it actually allows
Selina Kyle and it allows a
ventriloquist to have this interesting
conversation because it really did beg
the question you know who is this in
control when it comes to the
ventriloquist is it multiple personality
or is it the idea that the ventriloquist
himself um is really being subjected to
the control of a puppet and of course
during the conversations between the two
a Selina Kyle begins a scooping she's
like you know is it really just the
puppet er is at you you know and of the
mind the ventriloquist he's like no no
it's not just me the puppet really does
have control you know that's that's
really the monster he's really the one
making me do these things now for Selina
Kyle this is kind of cool you know
because she's like basically this guy's
got an out he completed sanity every
single time because you know to anybody
looking at him for what it is
he's got muscle personalities I mean you
know the mature Eliquis is just a
personality a counterpart to him now the
reason for this is because back in the
in the early days of Arnold Wesker's
life he was really timid he was really
meat he was for all intents and purposes
a coward he was scared of everything he
was always running and hiding from all
these different problems and things like
that but eventually his parents were
killed and in the emotional turmoil
really that came out of this experience
he basically ended up developing a
second personality that didn't manifest
until he came in contact with a guy
named Donegan I think it was and this
guy Donegan literally had a had a dummy
named named woody and the dummy began
talking to Arnold Wesker and eventually
helped him to escape
and the two of them just kind of went on
a crime spree but the fact remains here
that by his very nature of eyes very
definition Arnold Wesker is a guy who
just does what he's told he doesn't have
any initiative he has no no Drive no
ambition you'd never get anything beyond
what you tell him to do he's very much
robotic in that sense and so because of
that you know the scene account
basically says yeah I know Batman told
us that you're supposed to stay with me
but what I'm telling you is stay here
and so the initial indication here the
Tom King is giving us is that she's
breaking out of the plan that Batman set
for them now of course from here we pick
up with the other half of the plan in
the sense that Rod Steiger and punch and
Jewel had basically approached a santa
prisca prison with the idea that bronze
tiger himself was bringing punch
directly to directly to paint now the
reason for this is because punch was
like one of the only guys I think the
only guy who was able to successfully
break out of Santa Prisca prison so
because of this it's very much sought
after its who essentially having
returned home if for no other reason the
fact that mames just collecting trophies
the kicker to all this is that
real wha this conversations taking place
that man's watching it all unfold from a
vent a ventilation shaft Selina Kyle
jumps in you know and she basically
takes out bronze tiger and then she
spills the beans of the whole plan to
Bane and basically says the whole reason
why these guys are here is a ruse
they're supposed to be a distraction I'm
supposed to uh to take to kidnap
psycho-pirate Batman's got to jump back
in he's gonna fight you and while all
that's going on I'll make off a psycho
pirate and we'll get him back to Gotham
City and then everybody's just gonna
leave maybe they'll die maybe they won't
but that's the initial plan is for
everybody to make it out in the middle
of all this we have what looks like
Selena Kyle killing jewel and then
turning around killing punch it so it's
like okay this is really the worst case
scenario right here Catwoman just
destroying the entire plan that Batman
had laid down now what I was going
through this I was just kind of like
holy cow like this is extremely bad
because what this basically means is
that they're all most likely going to
die at the hands of Bane and so with
Batman more or less being a held
prisoner here or at the very least you
know kind of forced to submit to a
degree um it's the idea that they're
effectively going to take him out like
they're they're going to do him and uh
this it seems like it's the end of the
road for for Bruce Wayne now at this
point we have people who were just kind
of spread out in different locations and
so what's going on here and this is it
ducks you took a minute for this to kind
of sink in what's going on here is the
equivalent of a chess game anybody who
plays chess knows the worst thing you
could do is bunch your players up more
so than that you should always have your
pieces strategically placed in different
locations because the best way to
checkmate a player is to checkmate them
at a distance but it's also effectively
buxom in a reporter box away gets their
own pieces that's one of the best ways
to win but because of this think of
these guys as chess pieces we have
bronze Tiger who's basically been thrown
down you know in the pit with all the
other soldiers and the killers for hire
under Bane's control we have Arnold
Wesker who's still just kind of sitting
down on the sewers waiting for someone
to come and tell him what to do Jewel
and punch are dead they're being sent
off to the furnaces and Catwoman is
sitting alongside Bane while Batman
begins to find it now the other half of
this is that ain't is very much taunting
Batman in this skirmish you know Bane is
very much basically saying you know you
and I are exactly the same in a lot of
different ways now the argument Bane
makes here is good and it's very easy to
discount this but the argument that he
makes is actually pretty legitimate here
the reason why's Bane is extremely
intelligent I mean Bane what we saw in
the Dark Knight Returns you know in
terms of his strength
that was pretty cool what a turtle of
his intelligence it was nowhere near
what he needed to be at the end of the
movie he was still basically just a
henchman he was working for Talia al
Ghul spoiler alert for a seven-year-old
movie for this for the comics Bane was
always wildly intelligent he educated
himself you know he was able to deduce
Batman's identity and someone between
three to six months I think it was he's
one of the smartest guys when it comes
to combat strategy so on and so forth
and what he says what he tells Batman is
look you know over the course of my life
I thought venom was the answer I thought
that having this this substance that
would grant me super-strength would
allow me to achieve what it is that
would make this pain go away you know
that would make me feel like a better
person because I felt like I could do
anything but he said that's not the
answer the answer is actually
psycho-pirate psycho-pirate will make
you feel better all you have to do is
tell them that you want to be happy all
you have to do is tell them that you
want to be brave all you have to do is
tell him that you can always stop and so
he tells Batman tell me this tells
psycho-pirate this Batman responds by
saying all I want to do is I want to
break your back and that's when all the
chess pieces start moving around we
learned that Jewel and punch are not
dead they're very much alive their
bronze tiger is feeding for venom and he
basically starts attacking all these
different guys bronze tiger then turns
around and begins making his way back up
to where Batman is you know punch and
Jewel are basically using their tricks
or so on and so forth to basically
create air bubbles using gum so they can
you know jump out of the furnace they
can jump into the water come back up to
the surface without having to worry
about drowning by simply breathing in
the oxygen that they have in there now
of course this stretches the limits of
credulity but at the very least it makes
for an interesting story finally we
basically pick up with all these
different guys moving into the direction
of Arnold Wesker and we have bronze
tiger finally taking Wesker to bring him
to where Batman is located on top of all
this the plan seems to have been this
the entire time
Batman seems to have orchestrated this
the whole time because Catwoman keeps
saying you know do you want me to get
involved do you want me to get involved
in the finally Batman says break him and
Catwoman jumps in and breaks Bane's back
and so again this it seems to be the
entire plan of Batman to basically not
only defeat Bay where I just not only
take take psycho part but to crush thing
to basically say at the end of the day
you're nowhere near where I'm at you
know who you are right now is a
of your former self now a lot of this a
lot of the success still hinges on
arnold wesker the reason why is because
again psycho-pirate can manipulate the
emotions of anyone who sees him and so
because of this you know if he looks at
Batman if he looks at you know any of
these guys and targets them the hill
he'll send him into states of absolute
insanity by manipulating their emotions
but with Arnold Wesker is not that way
because Arnold Wesker is emotionally
repressed he doesn't allow his emotions
to get out there he's just a robot he
just does what he's told to do and so
because of this in the middle of
psycho-pirate moralist haunting Wesker
we suddenly have the personality of
woody the puppet emerging in the form of
a talking hand and this is really just
Arnold Wesker is defense his own
consciousness coming out and basically
saying no one can control me the only
person that could control Arnold Wesker
is of course woody you know no one
controls the ventriloquist so of course
because of this psycho pirates take it
out which leads to bronze Tiger taking
out Arnold Wesker to make sure that he
can't become you know too wildly
dangerous but again this just kind of
allows the story to to come to us to its
organic end with Batman taunting Bane
one last time by basically saying a
times going to come when you're gonna
want revenge you know when you're going
to want to come after me and when that
time comes don't because you're gonna
get more of the same and so what this
story does is it concludes with the
various guards of Bane you know coming
running in to his to his aid and the one
thing he keeps calling for is venom and
so the indication here is that Bane is
gonna go back to be in the same Bane he
used to be where he was all juiced up
and he was like three times the normal
size of a human being and he was
breaking Batman's back so Tom King's
Batman I am Bane is an incredibly
well-written story in truth it's one of
my absolute favorites the reason why is
because of the fact that Tom King has a
lot of similarities to Scott Snyder but
he's basically making Batman his own and
the stories really just kind of like
this multi-faceted thing I mean for the
first twenty issues of Batman rebirth
it's all about really bookending into
his battle with Bane wrapping things up
and then setting the stage for the
button's storyline of course when we
basically deal with the idea of the
Watchmen and the DC Universe but the
cool thing about this is it again much
like Scott Snyder
it's all-encompassing when Scott Snyder
first took over Batman with the new 52
what he basically did is of course he
gave us like quarter vowels for example
you know four issues 1 through 12
it was quarter vowels and city of owls
but the entire 12 issue run is
largely just kind of called the quarter
vowels storyline but it was a
multi-faceted story that basically
revealed to us as the reader that there
was an organization operating in Gotham
City the Batman never knew about called
the court of owls and it was cool to
turn the Batman mythos on his head where
we previously assumed the Batman always
knew what was going on in Gotham that in
truth he didn't know everything from
there it was the return of the Joker
death of the family in game there were
multifaceted story arcs that helped to
kind of revamp and revitalize the Batman
mythos for a new generation of readers
and that's one of the reasons why so
many people look to Scott Snyder's run
and say Scott Snyder and Greg Capullo
had the definitive storytelling standard
when it came to the Batman landscape and
so when Tom Kane took over it was a
tough nut to crack how many was a tough
sell for a lot of people to say can Tom
King live up to Scott Snyder's run in my
mind the answer is yes and the reason
why is because the whole first 20 issues
of Batman is really kind of like this
self-contained story but you have to
read in its entirety in order to fully
appreciate it and so what this story
what this video is gonna do is it's
gonna harken back all the way to really
the very first story of Batman rebirth a
very first issue of Batman rebirth and
kind of give us an idea of everything
that was going on behind the scenes with
regards to Batman's final confrontation
with Bane now what this does is this
picks up with the aftermath of I am
suicide there were a couple of one shots
between I am suicide and I am Bane but
they weren't wildly necessarily it was
kind of setting the stage and showing a
little bit of romance between Batman and
Catwoman and they were cool for what
they were but they're by no means
essential however the goal of Batman was
to make sure that basically capture
psycho-pirate now remember psycho-pirate
is a guy who can basically put on his
mask and then manipulate the emotions of
other people sending them into a state
of either total insanity of complete
happiness literally making them feel
whatever it is that he wants them to
feel with psycho-pirate impacting Gotham
girl who of course we had talked about
in the story I am Gotham with her having
really the powers that were almost on
par with Superman the idea was to
basically have her alongside Gotham turn
against Batman and send Gotham City into
a state of complete and total chaos the
idea was that ultimately Gotham was
killed and Gotham girl was taken by
Batman for the purpose of trying to
restore her back to her normal mental
state instead of just being in complete
and total fear all the time and so
because of this with Batman basically
you know in the events of I am suicide
capturing psycho-pirate what he did is
he
invaded the the island of Bane Santa
Prisca prison and then took
psycho-pirate away from him now
the reason why this is so significant is
because with this story picking up of
course it has us it really has Batman
engaging with bronze Tiger now on the
surface it seems as though bronze Tigers
kind of coming out of nowhere but this
is really a ruse that's been set up by
both Batman and bronze Tygra the reason
why is because this is designed for the
purpose of basically capturing
psycho-pirate and then bringing him into
contact with Gotham girl in order to
restore her mental state back to where
it's supposed to be now we'll see that
come to us for which we will see that
fleshed out here in a little while but
what we end up doing is we actually
switch over to bat burger and this is a
really cool point in the story this is
kind of funny and the reason why is
because of the fact we've got Bruce
Wayne alongside do Thomas and the guy
who's serving their food like they're
he's asking like you want to Joker eyes
your fries and everything's like that
I'd love to go to a restaurant where I
could like Joker eyes my fries like that
would be amazing it's almost like in and
out monsters like animal style oh my god
by the way in and out animal style fries
are amazing do they're so good I didn't
believe it before but they are
incredibly delicious but this is really
actually a meeting taking place between
the bath family so it will really -
Barbara Gordon or bat woman so it's
basically Duke Thomas and it's Bruce
Wayne and then Jason Todd Damian Wayne
and Dick Grayson by the funny thing is
we get this really cool interaction
between them you know for example Damian
Wayne basically gets a kid's meal and
then when he opens it up it turns out to
be a Red Hood toy and there's all kind
of you know all upset about and
everything but it's so kind of funny the
reason why this works is because again
and I keep reiterating this with Damian
Wayne he's one of my favorite characters
because he's so young and he's so
ruthless but he's also still a kid and
so he enjoys kids stuff but again what's
basically happening here is Bruce
Wayne's essentially telling everybody
look I'm going to have to take Gotham
girl for five days like I'm gonna take
her and I'm gonna have psycho-pirate
he's gonna interact with her for five
days Bane is gonna come looking for her
for five days you all need to leave
Gotham City you all have to get out of
here and the reason why is because Bane
will destroy anybody in his path in
order to get to the psycho part now the
reason why why this is the case and the
reason why Bane captured psycho apart in
the first place was because Bane is not
using venom anymore at least was not
using venom at the time the serum that
Gibson his enhanced strength and
durability and all that kind of good
stuff but coming off of venom is very
much like coming off of a drug there are
drawers in this case with venom it's
almost like the body's on fire and so in
order for Bain it basically overcome the
impact of venom without him being on it
he uses psycho-pirate to manipulate his
emotions solely body doesn't feel as
really as crushing as it would if he
didn't have the psycho-pirate
it's so literally taking psycho-pirate
away from Bain is taking away the one
thing that's keeping his a sanity intact
the one thing that's keeping his body
from feeling like it's destroying itself
and so because of this again Bruce Wayne
basically says you know they're going to
come after me like they're you know Bane
is going to come after me and he's gonna
come after you if you're around here
he's going to use everybody that he can
in order to force my hand and and
require me to give up psycho-pirate now
this is the other cool thing because
Robert Duke Thomas is still relatively
new to the idea of what it means to be a
sidekick or trainee of Batman of course
we know his role is different from like
Damian or Dick Grayson he's not a Robin
per se but he does have history with
Batman with the I am Robin storyline I
guess we are Robin storyline you know
and all these different little events
but he doesn't nearly have the
experience of Damien Damien Jason Todd
Dick Grayson any of those guys and so
into in Dukes mind he's still very loyal
to Batman and hasn't quite grasped the
the idea yet that when you are Robin
your number one responsibility is to
defy bats so because of that you know
you basically have Damian Dick Grayson
and Jason Todd who essentially race off
to go against Bane to try to find a way
to defeat Bane to make sure that he
can't harm Batman now at this point we
follow Bruce with Selina Kyle and again
this is a there's a lot of things that
happen off panel here that we'll find
out later on down the line but this
really seemed to be a little segment
that came out of nowhere in the sense
that there's some flirting between the
two but we don't really know everything
that goes on we just simply know that
for whatever reason Tom King is throw it
and in here and this is one of the
instances that I've been talking about
one of them has been been saying there
we go I can't talk the Tom Kings Batman
has been hit and missed for a lot of
people because there are things that
have been thrown into the story that
seemed totally irrelevant you know the
couple one shots that we had with Batman
and Catwoman where they were on a
rooftop you know doing their own thing
you know these instances here they seem
to come out of left field they seem to
have no place in the overarching story
but well we're gonna find out is that
they actually do
it's just Tom King has kind of been you
know working off panel and so what we
end up doing you know as we transition
back over to Wayne Manor alongside
Alfred Bruce Wayne and Gotham girl is
that once they get in the Batcave for
the purpose of trance
bring her over to Arkham without anybody
realizing what's going on when they get
into the cave they find the hung bodies
of Damian Wayne Jason Todd and Dick
Grayson now what this shows us is
exactly what we would expect that these
three guys do not stand a chance against
Bank not only that in this story we're
gonna see Bane at his absolute most
ruthless and the reason being because of
the fact that Bane is basically a
desperate man in this situation he's
really like a rabid animal in this
particular story and it's one of the
things that make him so cool of course
we'll cross that bridge when we get to
it but it's almost like a combination of
like Tom Hardy's Bane from The Dark
Knight Returns
combined with Bane as we traditionally
know him and come a book form and it
actually makes for a wicked combination
it is really really cool but from here
you know of course switching over to
bronze tiger essentially of course he
kind of answers the door out of nowhere
while he's still going you know coming
off the withdraws a venom only to be
shot in the stomach and so at this point
we pick up with Superman's Fortress of
Solitude and of course we basically have
Damian Jason and Dick Grayson being held
in stasis by Batman in the fortress of
solitude with Superman protecting them
now this raises a very interesting
question right off the bat when I first
saw this is why doesn't Batman ask
Superman for aid in fact why does a
Batman ask the Justice League for aid
any has but the idea behind this and
really the overarching theme behind DC
rebirth is to have a tighter knit
continuity among the various characters
as stories that have been going on that
was one of the biggest issues of DC you
as you would have virtually no
continuity Batman's the god of knowledge
in the Justice League while he's not
Batman in his own story because he's
just kind of m.i.a and so that lack of
continuity through people off with DC
rebirth continuity is the name of the
game DC is very much taking a page out
of value comics with how hardcore their
continuity has to be and so because of
that you know we have Batman speaking
with Superman the other half of this
though is that if Superman were to get
involved there would be no conflict
Superman would just pummel Bane and then
take him prisoner and that would be the
end of that there would be no you know
possibility of Batman's defeat there
would be no question of what happens
next you know none of that stuff it
would take away from the suspense of the
story not only that I just want to see
Batman fight Bane and so because of that
what we end up doing is we basically
have Batman telling Superman look I just
need you to keep these guys protected
now of course Superman doesn't have to
be and the fortress of solitude remember
it's Superman super-hearing the whole
nine yard
much like his you know connection with
Lois Lane here now if somebody were to
break into the fortress of solitude
Superman wouldn't know and he would be
there in an instant and so again it's
almost like a security system of sorts
in terms of Superman's powers but
switching back over to to Arkham Asylum
this is when we basically have Alfred
dressed as dr. Arkham alongside an
awesome girl who's disguised as hush
Thomas Eliot you know Batman's childhood
friend who you know eventually became an
enemy when they basically make their way
into to his cell recycler Pyrus being
held and the idea here is for
psycho-pirate to basically use his
ability or use his mask to begin
restoring the mind of Gotham girl now
this is one of the reasons why this is
so cool is because psycho-pirate spent a
prolonged amount of time with Gotham
girl manipulating her mind but it wasn't
five days you know manipulating her
emotions didn't take a full five days
but in this instance it will take that
to undo the damage and the reason why is
because of the fact that not only is
fear really one of the most potent
emotions when it comes to DC Comics we
know that with regards to the Sinestro
Corps the Green Lantern mythos the
emotional spectrum but also because of
the fact that Gotham girl has been
dealing with this altered emotional
state for quite some time and so the
damage is pretty intense and so the
psycho pirates going to have to
basically blast her with the full
potency of his abilities in order to
basically restore her mind back to where
it needs to be and of course this
basically picks up with him telling her
you know you're brave you're very very
brave and that kind of thing now
transitioning over to really to what I
consider to be the kind of highlight of
this conflict but we basically have you
know a few of Bane's henchmen who are
traveling around and rounding up
individuals who were either part of
Batman's team when they first broke into
Santa Prisca prison and stole
psycho-pirate
or individuals who were just close to
Batman so like Commissioner Gordon
Catwoman bronze tiger who was shot and
has basically been taken prisoner but
what is up happening here is Batman's
effectively just kind of perched up on
the Arkham Asylum clock tower and then
Bane just pops a flare and reveals that
he has Catwoman bronze tiger Duke Thomas
and Commissioner Gordon held hostage now
this is where the story gets really
really cool and that's where the things
about this is Tom Taylor when it comes
to like setting up a story he does it
pretty well but it seems to kind of drag
on a little bit and so what this is up
doing is just kind of going from zero to
60 really fast now one of the most
important things that he does is he
juxtaposes
is the history of Batman and Bane
together and this is what's so cool
because no one's ever really done this
before usually what they do is they say
hey here's like the origin story of Bane
and it's like a one shot or something
like that or it's somehow intertwined
into the story but we don't see Batman's
origin and Bane's origin side-by-side
with one another and the cool thing
about this is that that the Tom King
doesn't really change anything and he
doesn't like retcon the origin of Bane
order to make it fit the story he just
takes the origin of Bane as it exists in
DC Comics and then puts it side by side
with the origin of Batman as it exists
in DC Comics and what we find out is
these two are almost identical and
that's the coolest thing about this at a
young age they both they both lost their
parents of course Bane had lost his
mother but you know the motivation
behind them becoming who they were is
rooted in the loss of their parents you
know they both are motivated to become
better people they struggle with their
surroundings but when it comes to the
idea of where they end up ranching off
this comes in the form of the fact that
when they're when they basically undergo
the process of improving themselves they
enhance their minds they enhance their
physical bodies but where Batman looks
his experience and says I am going to
train myself to become someone more
capable I'm going to train myself to to
basically wage a war on crime Bane's
idea is that he's going to conquer crime
he's going to conquer anybody out there
who could pose a legitimate threat just
remain to do nothing more then establish
his dominance as a person in the world
out there and so again that's where
really their roads kind of started a
fork off but even then they're not that
dissimilar at that point it really just
kind of comes down to semantics you know
when it's batman waging a war on crime
he might as well be conquering criminals
when it comes to you know bane
conquering criminals he might as well be
waging a war on crime the only
difference is the end result where
Batman looks to criminals and says they
can be rehabilitated Bane says you now
work for me and so that's one of the
cool things it's really one of these
awesome Jackie O juxtapositions between
these two characters in terms of how
similar they are now the other half of
what goes on here is actually just a
direct fight between Batman and Bane and
Bane pulls no punches I mean he
absolutely wrecks Batman and is it's one
of the coolest things here because Bane
goes on this tirade motivation that says
I'm not a joke I'm not a riddle you know
I'm not a bird or cat or a penguin I'm
not any of your
out there I'm not some butler tending to
your wounds and telling you everything's
gonna be okay
I'm not some sidekick that's there to
have your back when things go under I'm
not some weakling I'm not some rich kid
that's basically trying to trying to
save the world I am vain and that's the
coolest thing about this is because it's
Tom King basically saying this is the
vain you know and love this is the bane
you want you don't want the bane this
kind of coming off you know coming off
then I'm you know people don't want the
bane that's just kind of you know has
enhanced strength to a degree people
want like the bane who broke the bat
they want nightfall bane and that's the
coolest thing that's one of reasons why
I love this so much that's why I think
Batman rebirth is the best thing coming
out of DC rebirth right now just because
of the fact that we get this awesome
amazing segment between these two
characters who historically have had so
much history between one another now
what is up happening here is that
because of the fact this is taking place
over the course of three or four days
that up Batman's basically kind of left
unconscious and that's it Bane tells his
guys kill everybody to know Commissioner
Gordon Duke Thomas you don't kill them
off well then of course we end up
finding out that what was happening off
panel with these different encounters
between Catwoman and Batman was that
they were setting this up that Batman
knew Bane would come for Catwoman it's
one of the reasons why he kept her there
similar because of the fact the Catwoman
knows that she's very capable when it
comes to escaping her confines when it
comes to her agility so on and so forth
she's really the one person in Batman's
corner who's almost guaranteed to make
an escape if she's captured by Bane and
so because of this what she did is she
freed Duke Thomas Commissioner Gordon
she freed all those guys bronze tiger
and then took Bane's guys hostage and so
what this does is it thins the playing
field what it does is it basically sort
of puts everything on the side of that
man with with Bane really having no
allies left on his side now of course
the conflict ends up leading directly to
Arkham Asylum itself and this I think is
really where the story begins to reach
its climax the reason why I say that is
because of the fact that with Bane
entering into Arkham we get this really
really cool segment from from Maximilian
uh Maximillian Zeus now those you guys
who don't know
Maximillian Zeus is basically just a
crazy guy but he has these amazing
monologues
he has like some of the some of the best
monologues in DC Comics because he runs
off like all these historical lines and
stuff like that but in this one he's
actually running off a segment
from I want to say the inferno the
inferno aspect of Dante's Divine Comedy
but it basically ends with you know all
hope abandon ye who enter here and so
it's really just like anybody who comes
in here is going to get decimated by
Bane the reason why we know this and the
reason why Zeus is even free in the
first place is because in order for
Batman to buy time he freed all the
criminals in Arkham Asylum and so it's
basically Bane against everyone and it's
like the coolest thing ever is one of
the coolest things because two-face is
the first one who encountered him
right you know in two phases look we're
of two minds you know the rational side
of me says Batman said that he would
basically improve my sentence if I
stopped you but then his chaotic and his
dark side says but if you have something
better to offer let me know and I'll
take your side Bane
punches him knocks him out and says I
offer pain that's what I offer
I offer pain to those who get in my way
and that's exactly what it does I mean
this that's God man for a boy that's why
this is so cool is because Bane is just
a force of nature right now I mean
Solomon Grundy not a chance
amygdala not a chance these are two
powerhouses in DC Comics two individuals
with insane levels of strength and Bane
takes them both out because remember
venom enhances his strength and it just
starts pumping that juice and that's the
end of them one of the other cool things
that we get to is we have like like
Solomon Grundy you know I'm Solomon
Grundy starts running off the born on a
Monday thing you know I make it was like
Alameda less so on and so forth Bane
says I am torment I am ruined I am
plague I am venom and that's what's so
cool about this is because it's just God
I love seeing this version of Bane it's
just it's so awesome because that's one
of the things that we've always wanted
to see right I mean bate has always been
like a thinking man's villain he's
always been extremely strong extremely
durable but one of the greatest aspects
of Christopher Nolan's version of Tom
Hardy Spain in the Dark Knight Returns
is just how insanely powerful he was I
mean just his sheer force of strength
was the ability for him to just overcome
Batman and there was no fight I mean you
guys know just as well as I do the first
fight between Batman and Bane that
wasn't a fight that was a murdering and
it was the coolest thing to see because
it was just
Batman getting completely dominated
because he was not prepared what we get
in this is still the thinking man's Bane
the one that we used that we know from
knife oh we get this smart being the
educated Bane the bane whose why
intelligent and uses that to his own
ends but because of the fact that he's
desperate to regain the psycho-pirate
he's now fallen down into this path of
being intelligent but also being a man
filled with nothing but rage and so
because of this he starts taking to
everyone and that's what makes us so
interesting now switching back over to
Bruce Wayne of course it's kind of crazy
because Bruce is talking with Alfred and
Alfred's like dude why why did you free
all those villains and Batman's
responses well we're just kind of buying
time now in truth this was a really
smart move by Batman you're Bruce Wayne
knows right off the bat these villains
are not going to stand a chance against
Bane right I mean there's they're not
going to be able to hold him down I mean
as long as he has that juice pumping
he's going to be an unstoppable force
but it's not the idea to stop bane
the purpose is to basically have a
stopgap measure
it's the basically slow Bane down in
order for Bruce Wayne to recover even if
only temporarily to basically kind of
regain his mind to bring yourself back
together and then to fight off Bane
again and so again you know with with
Bane continuing on it's mr. freeze gets
taken out Firefly gets taken out it's
one villain after another man-bat
Victor's as the Mad Hatter all these
guys keep getting crushed
you know Copperhead no one is able to
stop him no one's able to keep Batman
from from pulling off what he needs to
pull off now what Tom King also does
here is he begins the process of setting
up the war of jokes and riddles for the
larger Batman mythos of course it's
really really small here it's basically
Bane taking Riddler and having Riddler
put his mind to task with cracking this
massive door where psycho-pirate is
supposed to be held captive but what uh
what what Riddler also says is once the
doors open and Bane makes his way in he
simply just kind of runs it off is a
quick little line it's not too huge but
he says tell Batman I still remember the
war of jokes and riddles I still
remember what he made me do and you guys
know just as well as I do that he
deserves this and so again what this
does is lead up into this sort of final
conflict between Batman and Bane and
again that's why all this makes sense is
because with the story Batman basically
Ponder's his own death issue number one
when he first encountered Gotham and
Gotham girl you know when this plane was
was about to crash you know into end of
the Gotham Harbor when these two people
showed up seemingly out of nowhere with
enhanced strength and durability and the
power to fly you know basically all the
same abilities of Superman Batman look
at them and said
that's my way out and that's why Gotham
in Gotham girl were so significant and
that's why Batman is at least seems to
be going to the lengths to basically
preserve to restore Gotham grow back to
the way she was before because in that
story Tom King basically said the one
thing that we've known for years and
years and years and years and all the
time that we didn't we've been reading
Batman Bruce Wayne does not want to be
Batman Forever
eventually he wants to walk away he
wants to retire that's the basis behind
why do Thomas is here and is the basis
for why he paid special attention to
Gotham and Gotham girl because if he
trained them adequately they could be
the first in a new generation of heroes
who could protect Gotham City the way it
needs to be protected with Batman
finally relinquishing control and
stepping out of the shadows and allowing
himself to live a normal life or at
least a life as Noble as he could live
and so because of this it was it's
basically Batman kind of looking on at
this idea that everywhere he goes
destruction death and and failing is not
far behind
but if it means that he can defeat Bane
if it means that he can restore the mind
of Gotham girl then he was all worth
something at the same time again he
continues to ponder his death um he
tells Bane you have any idea how many
times I've been told I'm gonna kill you
you're gonna die tonight I've been told
that every single night since I become
Batman it's wearing thin it's getting
old
but what he also reveals here is that
all of this was done for the purpose of
buying time when he first came up with
the idea of taking psycho-pirate from
Bane he knew that there was going to be
fallout he knew that there was going to
be consequence all this stems with the
end of the of the i''m Gotham Soylent as
soon as Gotham girls mine had basically
unwarped by psycho-pirate Batman said we
have to get psycho-pirate back
psycho-pirate is a source for Bane in
order to allow Bane to overcome his
addiction to venom because of that Bane
is going to be a wrecking machine as
soon as we take psycho-pirate all these
fights all these conflicts everything
that's happened in the story so far is
just for the purpose of buying time but
it's also bringing to an end this
massive battle between the two now the
other cool thing about this is that
Batman recollects on his own history he
looks back at his own past and really
begins to realize how similar he is to
Bane but their roads led them down two
different paths and that's really what
Tom Taylor is hitting home here when it
comes to the characters of Bane and
Batman yes they're very similar yes
their origins are almost entirely
identical the difference is that Batman
is ruled by his past and Bane is not now
that's kind of crazy because we would
expect it to be the other way around
because what this does is it basically
forces Batman into the situation where
he's governed by his own destiny he
doesn't control his own destiny he's
controlled by it you know Batman is
ruled by fear
Batman's ruled by fear the fact that
somebody else out there will experience
the same situation he experienced with
his parents now that gives him strength
to do what he does every day but instead
of him controlling his own life
controlling his own destiny he's
governed by it his road was set the
instant that his parents died now with
bane it's not necessarily the case
Bane chose his path Bane chose to go
onto the road of becoming a bad guy
chose to go on the road to becoming a
villain but then that asked the question
what would have happened if he had
chosen a different path what would have
happened if he had chosen the same road
as Batman where he decided to wage a war
on what would have happened if the two
of them had come together as allies
what kind of work could be done in
Gotham City if they both function
together and so that's why this story is
so cool is because it begs those
questions but in the end of course
Batman you know is bane continue saying
you know I am Bank Batman's responses
yeah I know I've heard it before but I'm
Batman and just headbutts the hell out
of Bane and essentially knocks them
unconscious and so what this does is it
basically brings an end to the battle
between these two there's something to
be said about the conflict here because
it's really kind of like this final
battle almost indicative of you know the
Batman versus Joker in Scott Snyder's
in-game and that's one of the reasons
why I say you know Tom King is very
similar in terms of how he's more or
less mirroring scott Snyder's Batman in
terms of how he adds in Bane but it's
still its own style of storytelling so
it's really kind of cool it's one of
those cool situations where they do
stand side by side but they are still
different at the same time but what this
does is it really kind of has Batman
sort of having this imaginary
conversation with his mother who's now
deceased and the idea is you know is
really him coming to grips with her
death in a lot of ways you know where he
basically says look all this has been
about is saving Gotham girl you know
it's keeping this girl's life intact is
giving this girl a chance to live a
normal life and of course it really sort
of ends with his mother telling him look
you don't have to die in some grandiose
way to make me proud everything you've
done is has made me proud the fact that
you've lived up to our legacy done the
best you could for Gotham City both
financially as Bruce Wayne as well
Batman in terms of your war on crime and
so again it's really just kind of him
coming to grips with his own history
coming to grips with his own his own
life but it's really kind of one of
these these interesting things we asked
one of the reasons why I like this story
is because it basically just sort of
wraps up everything that's happened in
the last 20 issues and then it sets the
stage for the next phase of Tom King's
run which will focus on you know the
whole button story off the idea of the
Watchmen being in the DC Universe oh my
god Rob core okay so check us out this
story is called the brave and the mold
like if that gives you any indication of
what it's about and I swear to god this
story is hilarious it's like the best
thing coming out of DC rebirth right now
like it's it's absolutely one of my
favorite stories with Batman now here's
the funny thing
this has Swamp Thing and like I've never
read Swamp Thing I'm a little ashamed to
admit it I have never read Swamp Thing
once in my life like I've never read a
single comic of his I heard that like
the new 52 Swamp Thing is really really
good but I've never read it before and
it's kind of weird because he's like a
pop culture or mainstay right like most
everybody knows what's going on like
like who's Swamp Thing is when they see
him but I can't even read anything about
him so this is like my first real
exposure in comics to his character and
it's amazing so here's a years ago thing
so initially this picks up I mean
technically it's kind of like chapter
two they kind of split into chapters
like the old anthology books from the
1940s and 50s and 60s where you would
have like a singular book that would go
on for 30 pages but you would have like
Part 1 which would be like four pages
apart two might be six pages or chapter
one chapter two setting on those lines
but all that really happens here is just
like some guy in an apartment is shot in
the head and he's kind of singing this
really haunting song this is actually
picked up on by by Jim Gordon and Batman
now this is where things get hilarious
because with the character of soif The
Swamp Thing from what I've read and for
what I understand he's tied into
something called the green and that I'm
pretty familiar with just because of the
whole lot injustice stories but the way
it works as far as I'm aware the wait
originally worked his Swamp Thing was
just kind of like this outlier in DC
Comics he was just kind of out there in
no-man's land like Hellblazer in the
Vertigo stories he was just kind of out
there by himself and he really wasn't
tied in to like the rest of DC but with
the new 52 DC rolled him into the shared
universe and what they did is they came
up with an idea called the green and
what they basically said was that
in the realm of DC's landscape you've
got the green which is plant life you've
got the red which is animals you've got
the black which is rot it was almost
kind of like this earth-based equivalent
to like the emotional spectrum from the
Green Lantern mythos but the fact
remains that swampthing is tied to the
green much like poison ivy and so what
this means is that he is effectively
immortal I mean as long as plant life
exists he will exist and he can
literally just kind of like reconstitute
himself take on additional masks he has
strength of a level that's never been
calculated before is incredibly capable
in terms of what it is that he can do
but that's about the extent of my
knowledge on his character after reading
this story I'm almost inclined to go
back and read the new 52 Swamp Thing
just to see if it was really that good
um I have no idea how long it went on
for it I can't imagine it went on too
long 52 issues is what everything ran
for in the new 52 because they were all
monthly titles so it's not like it was a
super lengthy thing but but the fact
remains here the Swamp Thing basically
just kind of reconstitutes himself or
you know forms out of some plant matter
and just kind of makes his presence
known to Tim Gordon now this is a funny
thing because that man knows who's Swamp
Thing is right so that man's just kind
of like looking at the crime scene and
analyzing things and Jim Gordon is just
like okay like this giant swamp monster
just kind of emerged behind us and I
really feel like that needs to be said
right now like I really feel like we
have to acknowledge that this happened
and it's just funny to see people
reacting to this and that's one of the
things I love about about Kings riding
is because he gives the characters so
much character like Jim Gordon is just
this guy this like okay I mean I guess
it was only a matter of time before
something like this happened we live in
a world where bullets bounce off of a
man because he's an alien we've got a
guy who flies around at night or just
like glides around at night dressed as a
bat beating people up it makes sense
that there would be a giant guy who's
composed of you know plant matter
appearing in the middle of a room and a
crime scene but it's kind of cool
because while this is happening Batman's
just like is there a problem he's just
he's totally responding to Swamp Thing
as if he's an old person now from here
we switch over to Alfred and this again
is another funny scenario because Swamp
Thing being being composed you know of
compost you know being a giant compost
heap it's just kind of like leaving
marks and stuff on the ground leaving
plant marks on the ground you know
Alfred cleans this kind of stuff up but
it's just like yeah it's all
for the course when you're offered it's
just kind of the way it goes you know
messes get brought in by the giving
tree' things just come in messes get
made and that's really yet but again
it's one of these kind of cool things
now the interesting thing about this is
that Tom King is so good at characters
and this is where the story really kind
of starts to shift a bit towards the
character development and the reason why
is because with Swamp Thing there is no
such thing as death at least as far as
he explains it here to Bruce Wayne there
is no such thing as death a person comes
from the earth they come from life
evolution averages you want to look at
it they come from divine intervention
they die so to speak but they become one
with the earth and in turn they feed
plants and they feed trees which provide
life-giving oxygen or nourishment to
different you know critters and
organisms across the world and so
there's always kind of like this cycle
of life and death so to speak but no
one's ever really dead and that's what
makes us so cool is because in his mind
he basically says look you know this man
who was killed is my father he sent me
letters beep tried to talk to me I've
spoke to a maybe once after the whole
instance with the swamp where I became
something and that was really it like
this guy never really had a role in the
life of Alec Halden instead he was just
kind of disguised and Alec knew about
but never really did anything with now
the reason why this matters and the
reason why this is so cool is because
what it does is it bridges the gap
between Bruce Wayne and Swamp Thing
Swamp Thing is this guy where he's
basically like I have this man who's my
father then I'll never be able to talk
to anymore I'll never be able to like
converse with I'll never be able to
learn more about him not that I ever did
know much about him in the first place
but now that I want to know about him I
can't because he's effectively gone I'll
never be able to speak to him in the
conventional sense vo with Bruce Wayne
it's much the same way his mother and
father were killed in front of them
he'll never be able to talk to Thomas
Wayne he'll never be able to talk to
Martha Wayne he'll never be able to get
their opinions get their ideas ask them
do I make you proud that's one of the
most significant moments about the
button that's why the encounter between
thomas wayne from the flashpoint
universe and bruce wayne from the main
DC Universe was so significant because
even if it's not his biological father
industry in the traditional sense it's
still his father you know it's still the
thomas wayne that he knew albeit just a
different version of thomas wayne and it
was emotional and it was visceral and it
was amazing and so because that it
creates some real emotional tie to these
characters if that kind of makes any
sense and so ultimately when is up
happening here is it's waffling
basically says look I'm just kind of
here because I'm
interested in solving this murder that
really kind of seems to be it I mean
it's like look my dad was killed I want
to know what's going on now the initial
indication here from Bruce Wayne is that
this man was murdered on like the 84th
floor of a building and there's only a
handful of people who could have been
the ones responsible for that now the
first one he goes after is kite man and
kite man do kite man is amazing so cool
all this guy does is fly around and yell
kite man hell yeah that's all he does
like that's his thing that's his whole
ordeal now of course the cool thing
about this is that Tom King very much
plays on the idea of like what Batman's
about right like we know as the Batman
is the guy who doesn't kill but the bad
guys don't need to know that the bad
guys just need to believe they're gonna
die and if your kite man and your your
soaring 500 feet above the ground
and Batman latches on to you and will
not let you go the only thing racing
through your mind is you're going to
smash into the ground and Batman is
gonna let you die he's gonna bail out
and you know what second before it
happens he's gonna live but kite man's
gonna be done with all his living that's
it was kind of cool because I mean we
know this is not gonna happen we know
he's not gonna die but the questions a
Batman has is you know who is it that
committed this crime or how would they
have gained access to the resources
necessary to commit this crime because
kite man didn't invented his own stuff
he got his stuff from somewhere else so
again it's really kind of like one of
these whodunit mystery sort of things
and so what cat man basically says is
that he grabbed his stuff from a guy
named Mooney money now of course Mooney
money is clearly a comic book stand in
for Guy Fieri but the fact remains here
that going through all these different
sources and jumping through all these
different guys eventually Batman you
know basically realizes that this murder
seems to have been done by a guy by the
name of headhunter now headhunter is a
guy that I know nothing about I don't
know if he's new I don't know if he is a
character that was recently created I
really don't like using Wikipedia's just
because anybody can edit them but I
don't know anything about that guy but
really the only explanation we need is
what's offered here where he's basically
just like a mercenary and he always
executes his victims by shooting them
twice in the head and no one knows why
he shoots a second time but the funny
thing about this is that Bruce Wayne
kind of hints at this and says look this
guy is gonna be hard to find because he
basically commits his crimes he goes
underground he goes on the run and then
he only resurfaces whenever he's ready
to commit another murder and so the guy
is sporadic I mean he pops up here he
pops up there but there's no pattern to
what it is that he does outside of the
murders that he commits and so it's
really kind of a cool
mário because what this shows us is that
even within the realm of Gotham City or
even the world as a whole there are some
people out there who were just that good
at evading Batman they're just that good
at evading him and again it makes Bruce
Wayne more realistic it makes him more
grounded and makes him more tangible and
basically telling us that despite all of
his vaunted resources all of his wealth
all of his capabilities at the end of
the day he is still only human and he
can only do what a normal human can do
and so because of this Swamp Thing
basically chimes in and says he's
currently entering the the Gotham Museum
of Art and when Batman's like how did
you find that out
swampies response is that the grass told
him and that's the coolest thing about
this because like the grass or if you're
talking to the grass that's cool
whatever man do what you do man you be
you I'll be me and we'll call it a day
and so it's just really kind of funny to
see these interactions between these
characters who would normally never meet
because they're so starkly different
right I mean Batman is hanging out with
plant metal as they're going to
investigate a murder and so again it's
interesting to kind of see how these
characters relate to one another how
they deal with one another now of course
once they get to the Gotham Museum they
immediately encounter headhunter and
headhunter really just kind of starts
talking about how he had killed this guy
he had killed the father of Swamp Thing
just because of the fact that he was
sort of bragging about how he knows he
rose or he's has an in with superhero so
to speak only and so far that he knew
his son was Swamp Thing and that was
really about it but it was one of these
scenarios where it was this situation
where a guy was basically spouting off
of the mouth in the wrong place at the
wrong time and headhunter effectively
killed him you know basically killed him
for that purpose now in response to this
Swamp Thing immediately kills headhunter
like he just immediately crushes him you
know Batman its kind of begging him to
stop the whole time but as soon as he's
done
you know Swamp Thing starts crying and
basically talking about how his father's
dad he's never gonna be able to talk to
his father again Batman's immediate
response is like what happened to like
there is no death what happened to like
everything lives on you know it's like
light descending and all that stuff like
what happened to that things like nah
man he's just dead that's basically what
it is and Batman's so pissed like that
man reads him the riot act he is so
pissed off because in the mind of that
man Swamp Thing used him right like
Swamp Thing shows up with this whole
dog-and-pony show up oh well you know
enough
things are really dead everything just
kind of lives on knowing the full of
plant life and different things like
that
you know but it's basically him just
kind of turned coding here just being
like that's it man everything's dead you
know there's there's that's that's
there's nothing to a man like you die
and then that's it like that's just the
end of you you know and it's kind of
crazy because while Batman's reading him
the riot act
Swamp Thing is like I gotta go and he
basically just bails out and that's it
and it really just kind of ends with
Batman screaming at him that's pretty
much all there is to it it is an amazing
story this is so good it is a perfect
ending to a Batman story and I really
hope this question goes out to you guys
who are Swamp Thing fans my question is
this is the new 52 Swamp Thing like this
or is it just like kind of weird and
dark and so on because this is an
amazing story and I absolutely love this
I love seeing Batman reading Swamp Thing
the wry not because like Swamp Thing
could crush him like a bug right like
some thing would be like you know what
I'm tired of you Batman
and then that's just the end of Bruce
Wayne it'd be so cool like it's such a
cool scenario to see Batman just not
caring and just screaming at Swamp Thing
and The Swamp Thing just being like I'm
out peace and just bailing Rob core man
y'all know what I'm getting ready to say
Batman the best thing coming out of DC
rebirth right now oh I'll do this story
is so good man this story is so good
like Tom King man Jason man this man's
living up to his namesake he's the king
of writing Batman right now mostly
because he's the only one right in the
Batman comic Detective Comics is good
Detective Comics is amazing
I love Detective Comics but this right
here with Batman is amazing in all
seriousness stuff this is a beautifully
written comic I mean a beautifully
written comic because there's no like
villains
there's no bane coming there's no all
the Joker no none of that stuff
this is Batman at his most real this is
Batman like Batman's characters tangible
you feel it's the cool thing about this
is this really kind of offers like a
follow-up to the whole events with
Gotham girl and it was always like this
unresolved hotline right like it as
things been going on forever and ever
and ever and ever and it's just never
really been resolved even now we still
don't know a lot about her all we really
know is that in the beginning of Batman
rebirth that Gotham and Gotham girl had
just shown up in Gotham City you know
and they had these powers that made them
almost akin to Superman they could fly
they had durability and hand strength so
on and so forth now over the course of
the story Gotham of I am
awesome movie it learned is that
somewhere along the line they had
effectively sold years of their lives
in relation to power which meant that if
you wanted like absolute power you would
have to basically say here's the X
amount of years that I'm willing to give
away what that really means is that the
more she uses her powers the more she
drains years off her life and so she's
kind of at this impasse because if she
decides to become a superhero she's
gonna start losing more of her life if
she doesn't she can live out the rest of
her days or whatever day she has left as
a person and that's really the crux of
this story in a lot of ways with the
exception of the ending but the cool
thing about this is that with the
character of Gotham girl because she's
so powerful she was one of these people
that basically had her emotions messed
with by psycho-pirate and so as a result
she spent most all of the storylines
after the events of I am Gotham she
spent all the other storylines just kind
of sitting in fear now of course this is
really kind of Kings way of putting
around the back burner of just saying
hey look we're gonna save her for later
but for right now if we have somebody
fighting as part of the bat family then
had strength and power that basically
made them equivalent to Superman then it
would just solve all the problems that
are coming along Batman fights Bane
gotham girl swoops in and saves the day
it would cause all kinds of issues cuz
fans would be like well why does he
gotham girl just do anything so it
allows her to be put on the back burner
but having recovered from her whole
experience with regards to the the mecha
nations of psycho-pirate puts her in a
position now to where she can basically
decide what she wants to do next because
it's really kind of a fresh start for
her and the cool thing about this is
that it really asks all these important
questions with regards to Bruce Wayne as
a character because with Gotham girl
kind of pondering what she's gonna be
next is she gonna be a superhero is she
gonna be an ortley gonna live a normal
life she asked these questions to Bruce
Wayne because he's really the first
guidance that she's ever really had and
being a superhero keep in mind Gotham
girl in Gotham gained their powers they
decided one they wanted to be
superheroes but they didn't have any
real training they didn't go to the
Justice League and say teach us how to
be superheroes Batman was the first time
they encountered a superhero in Batman
is a very unique case among the
superhero community because he's so
capable but he's also just mortal all
they would take is for someone to know
Bruce Wayne's identity and then to be
sitting on a rooftop on a building
somewhere with a sniper rifle Bruce
Wayne gets out of his car he goes to
walk into Wayne Enterprises he gets shot
in the head and that's the end of Batman
I mean that's all it would take a story
like that wouldn't be very fun like he's
just the death of Batman I think it's
three pages long it would not be
interesting at all but you know that's
that's what it
for this character but he's so unique
he's so interesting because he's so
smart he's so easily killed that's what
makes the thing so cool about him but in
a lot of ways he's also the first
superhero that Gotham Girl has really
encountered they can teach her what it
means to be a superhero to go out and
live a normal life and it's kind of
interesting you know because is she
asked a question what would I do like
you know what were where would I go and
it's kind of funny because she says I
was hoping he would just point me in the
right direction I was hoping that all
this would be done to my emotions would
be be back under control you know you
would give me a piece of paper and say
follow these rules and you'll have a
normal life that's what she was hoping
for was for him to basically hold her
hand and guide her to where she needed
to go to become a hero but at the end of
the day it's not like that because it's
not like that for anyone
there aren't there's no rulebook on how
to live life there's no guidebook on
what you should do and what you
shouldn't do in me it's not like you're
born you know and then you get to the
point where you go through elementary
school and middle school and high school
you know when you're ready to go off to
college you get you're 18 years old you
get your first job and your parents say
okay here's the book of life have fun
and all you have to do is just go
through the pages as you encounter
situations kind of pay bills what credit
means I mean there's no guidebook for
that kind of a stuff I think I'm gonna
start a YouTube channel like where I
just where I do that the guide book to
life I have no idea but nonetheless you
know these are things that she's
literally learning not for her the idea
of paying bills things like that I mean
that's not essential but you guys
understand what I'm saying there's no
guide book on how to be a superhero and
that's the kind of crazy thing is
because that's why each member of the
Justice League is so significant you
know despite the fact that he's
basically the security guard slash guy
that hangs around you know and just like
watches whatever he washes on TV black
mirror I have no idea cyborg plays a
role in the Justice League Superman is
the backbone he's the guy where
everybody knows no matter how bad things
get it's not over unless Superman's
incapacitated Wonder Woman the one who
will fight until the bitter end Batman
is the brains of the operation Green
Lantern he's the one that's like look if
things get really bad I've got a whole
army behind me that I can just bring in
to unleash absolute hell everybody has a
role to play with Gotham girl she's
figuring out her role she's figuring out
her life she's really kind of just
having this existential crisis right now
she doesn't know where she belongs
she doesn't know who she's supposed to
be here what she's supposed to be about
and Batman says that Batman says look
when it came down to it following the
death of my parents sure Alfred said hey
look here if they
you're supposed to do you know here's
how you live your life here's how you
become a man but when it came to him
becoming a superhero there was no
guidebook Batman did the best he could
he suddenly came across a guy who was
dogging this Red Hood they got into a
fight Red Hood fell into of that and
became the Joker you commit to actions
you do things they have consequences and
you navigate and chart those waters as
best you can but the funny thing about
this is that this creates a lot of
questions in the mind of Bruce Wayne
remember we did the button at the end of
the button or during the events of the
button he came face to face with his own
own father Thomas Wayne but that version
of Thomas was more significant than the
actual new 52 version of Thomas that was
shot in that alley and the reason why is
because the flashpoint version of Thomas
Wayne saw his son died he saw that
version of Bruce Wayne killed his wife
Martha Wayne became the Joker these are
the kind of things that he dealt with
and so when he sat down with Bruce and
he said go live your life do not live
your life as Batman do not live your
life fighting crime go and live a life
go make a life for yourself find the
woman settle down start a family hasher
your knowledge on to the next generation
let's somebody else be Batman go and
live what he's finding himself doing
here is reiterating that exact same
advice to Gotham girl and she's in turn
asking well then why don't you follow it
if that's advice that you think is so
sound if this advice that you think it's
illegitimate then why aren't you
following it and this is the beauty of
all this this is this is the beauty of
the whole conversation that they have
Batman says because I don't know how to
not be Batman I don't know how to be
anybody else that's who I am
that's what I am my parents were shot in
an alley I'm terrified you know that I'd
have to relive that experience I'm
terrified of losing the things I care
about the only way for me to cope with
that situation is to become Batman
Batman became an ingrained part of Bruce
Wayne so much so that Bruce Wayne is the
costume it's the face he puts on when he
goes out in public when the Sun Goes
Down when the criminals come out Batman
comes out and that's who Bruce Wayne
really is he doesn't know how to be
anything else and that's what's so cool
about this is because this hitting home
it's telling us the one thing that we as
Batman fans always knew it didn't take a
genius to know that like Batman was the
character Bruce Wayne is just the guy
that we see occasionally that's just
that's the way it's always been but it's
so cool to just kind of see that thrown
on you know in pen and paper and ink
that that's what it is
that Bruce Wayne is just he doesn't know
how to be anybody else
but Batman not only that the idea of
of failing to him is a massive calamity
it's something that he's absolutely
terrified of not only that while he
tries his best to live a normal life
while he tries his best to do the things
that ultimately work for him at the end
of the day he's afraid of what it means
to not be Batman and because of that he
fails he basically sets himself up for
failure he sits down in his home in the
comfort of his own home in front of a
fireplace with a glass of scotch and
asked the question
I wonder what life would be like if I
wasn't Batman but he looks around the
city of Gotham and he says I'm the last
bastion of hope here I'm the last man
standing I'm the last fig-leaf if I stop
being Batman this city gets overrun the
cops can hardly do the job on their own
the only reason why the city is where it
is now is because I operate outside of
the law I can bend the rules I can break
the rules I can make people talk who
wouldn't talk I can make people talk who
wouldn't talk to the cops they wouldn't
be able to get the information they need
I can swoop in in the dead of night I
can make people so scared to commit
crimes that they don't rob banks but
they don't mug people in the streets
some do but at the end of the day the
biggest threat to the city of Gotham
other big guys the Joker the penguin
two-face those are the kind of things
that we have to worry about and so in a
lot of ways he's done his job but his
biggest fear is that if he steps down
and he walks away then Gotham's just
right for the pickings word gets around
them the Batman's gone oh my god the
Batman Scott dude the city is ours and
suddenly it just descends into absolute
madness and so while he wants to live a
normal life he can't because he fraid
he's afraid that if he does he'll fail
the city of Gotham and if he fails the
city of Gotham he'll fail his parents
and that again is why it's also
important because at the end of the day
it's like that same line it's like the
line that we saw in in injustice to that
thread doesn't change no matter what
universe we're in if Batman or I'm sorry
of Bruce Wayne is Batman then it's the
same thing all the time no matter what
he looks like no matter what you know
huge calamity he's engaged in no matter
what enemy he's fighting or how big his
Justice League team is at the end of the
day the man under that cloak and cowl is
a little boy who's crying because his
parents got shot in an alley that's
what's so cool about it and that's what
makes it so interesting is because
that's who Batman is and so taking this
advice you know when he says look this
conversation is not about me and and you
know Gotham girl says that's the problem
the conversations not about you we need
to make it about you Batman has to
really ask himself take a good look
Tamir and say am I really doing
everything I can to live a normal life
am I am I really in this position where
I've tried everything that I can and so
what he ends up doing is he goes to
Catwoman and this is why it's so
gorgeous because it's not like a
knee-jerk thing it's not like you know
King was sitting right in the stories
like you know what I wonder what would
happen if like Batman proposed to
Catwoman let's just see let's just let's
just have it come out of nowhere now
it's a gradual work in it's a gradual
thing it starts you know really all the
way back I would daresay with with Scott
Snyder's run but it really picked up
steam with Batman rebirth it starts with
the introduction of Gotham of Gotham
Grove the possibility existing that
Batman can train these two new people so
that he can go and have a life for
himself only to find out that one of
them goes crazy ends up being killed by
his sister and the sisters emotions are
manipulated by psycho-pirate and she
ends up having to be taken care of and
it's right back to the way it was before
right back to the way things were before
Bruce Wayne's gotta be Batman and he's
got to keep Gotham City safe and he's
got a train do for whatever it is that
he's got to do and then suddenly it's
Bane oh my god Bane's back it's the same
thing over and over and over and over
again and then he goes to be rihanna
says hey let's do some investigation
about this button eobard thawne shows up
eobard thawne just wreaks absolute havoc
on Batman disappears reappears rants
about having seen God Barry Allen and
Batman jump into the timestream
Batman runs into his own father Thomas
Wayne Thomas Wayne says go live your
life the world the universe the
multiverse is screaming at Bruce Wayne
go live a life man quit being Batman go
live a life go do your thing and so what
does he do he finally after so many
years follows the universe's advice
follows the multiverses advice everybody
says go live a life and he does he goes
to Catwoman in one of the most beautiful
moments that I've ever seen in a comic
book
he goes to Catwoman it says from the
time I first met you I knew that you
were gonna be the one whether it was
because opposites attract whether it was
because she was just so willing to do
whatever it took in order to pull off
whatever goal it was she was trying to
achieve at the end of the day he says
I'm terrified of what it is that I'm
about to do I'm so scared that I might
lose you the one connection that I have
to what it can mean to have a real life
I'm terrified of what it means to
possibly take this step because it means
I'm gonna step down from the life that
I've had but regardless of it all he
tells Catwoman he loves her and he
proposes to her the reason why this is
so visceral is because any man who's
ever proposed to a woman will tell
any any man who's ever proposed to a
woman will probably tell you it was the
most terrifying moment of my life
because what if she says no but for
Bruce Wayne it's not terrifying because
maybe she'll say no it's terrifying
because of what this represents it's
terrifying because of what this means
with Bruce Wayne being Batman the reason
why he's kept so many people at arm's
length the reason why he's kept so many
people distant is the possibility of
losing them so much loss in his life he
looks around and says if I proposed a
Catwoman if I take this step if I lose
her it could shatter me it could break
me in a way that I never imagined but in
the end he does it he takes that step
because he's ready for something new
he's ready for a new era of his own life
and that's why this is so great because
what this does is it bolsters the
Batman's story now because now he's got
his own Lois Lane he's got his own Mary
Jane Watson he's got his own a love
interest in his life but he has to hold
on to because she's now the closest
thing he has to what it means to live a
normal life but without being said guys
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob Corddry guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like god this was an amazing story this
is actually gonna lead into the war of
jokes and riddles which I'm really
really excited about but oh my god was
this beautifully written
DC Comics Bravo Bravo
this was amazing is the best thing
coming out of DC rebirth right now
absolutely stellar I really hope that we
get more stuff like this it's one of the
reasons why I love Kings Batman so far
because it's just been astronomically
amazing and this is just the cherry on
top it's the icing on the cake
beautifully done okay
so the war of jokes and riddles is
amazing this story is incredibly good in
this video we're covering part one and
then we'll probably upload a second
video either later on today or later on
this week that will be part two the
conclusion of the whole thing but the
war of jokes and riddles is incredible
dare I say the best thing coming out of
DC rebirth right now it is probably one
of the best stories that I've read in a
long time involving Batman but this
comes directly out of the aftermath of
zero year which we've covered and you'll
find that down in the Batman playlist in
the description what this also does is
it basically follows up to the idea that
Bruce Wayne has only been Batman for a
very short amount of time and so this
story is basically a retcon now for
those of you guys who were familiar with
comics and you know that is bear with me
for a second for the people who don't
reckon is basically it's it's short for
retroactive continuity and what it means
is that a writer will basically go back
to a particular character and put
something in their comics that wasn't
there before this is basically a story
that was never told before it was a set
of events that had never been hinted to
you we didn't know anything about it and
it's basically just throwing it in there
now saying this actually happened and
it's essentially a war between the Joker
and the Riddler and it is god it is
incredible so the cool thing is that
when it came to Batman 0 year when it
came to like the origin of the Joker
different things like that the idea was
that it was telling the story of how the
Joker became the Joker but it fit in
with the notion of the fact that the
Joker is a guy that will always be one
of Batman's main villains if not his
most significant villain and so because
of that and following the events of zero
year but Joker had just sort of taken
off you know the guy who had become the
Joker eventually became the Joker and
then he would just fight Batman later on
what this does is it takes place before
a lot of the Joker stories that we saw
after zero year what it also does is
featuring you know kind of talking about
the Riddler for a second the idea was
that the Riddler was a little more
involved in a little more complex and
more developed in terms of you know his
storytelling now the reason for this was
simple the idea was that when new 52
first launched and writer Scott Snyder
was basically crafting his run on Batman
the idea was to bring the Joker back
later on down the line during death of
the family technically speaking death of
the family is the first major storyline
that we that we see that features the
Joker when the new 52 first launched
back in 2011 following that was Batman
in-game but the idea was that because
the Joker was basically put on the back
burner to be used at a later date
Snyder sort of focusing on things like
the court of owls and the night of owls
and different things like that two-face
and Riddler and so on and so forth so
Riddler got a lot more attention from
Snyder and it basically dealt with the
idea of the Riddler taking over Gotham
City setting up all these traps using
the various abilities of different
villains and then ultimately being
caught and then being being arrested and
thrown in jail the cool thing about this
is that Edward nygma in a lot of ways I
would say is more dangerous than the
Joker is the reason for this is because
of the fact that yes the Joker is crazy
and yes the Joker zany and yes you never
know what he's gonna do but Riddler is
all about elaborate schemes elaborate
traps he may start a sequence of events
and the conclusion of those events will
not be
come readily available or won't even be
understood until maybe months or even
years after they originally start and
that's the cool thing about him is
because while he's in jail what he
actually starts doing is making friends
and talking to people now it's really
friends in the sense of the fact that
because he was so good at figuring out
puzzles and riddles and so on that what
he did is he became a source for various
cops who were trying to figure out ways
to solve crimes that they could not
solve on their own and what it did it
had been kind of an essential figure in
the sense that a lot of cops began to
get to a point where they needed him one
cop in particular is basically killed by
the Riddler who in turn begins
engineering his own escape and that's
kind of the danger of it all is because
what we end up finding out is that one
of the guys the Riddler was talking to
you ah
The Riddler didn't ask for anything in
particular he wasn't asking for money he
wasn't asking for resources
he just wanted information about other
cops and the reason why is because when
he goes to make his escape he starts
running off the names of all these
different cops family members their
wives their children their son basically
being told the names of these people
which in turn he's going to use as part
of his plan to work perfectly for him
because he doesn't have to lift a finger
he doesn't have to shoot a person or
anything all he has to do is just say I
know who the people are that you care
about and bad things will happen to them
if you do not let me go and ultimately
that's exactly what they end up doing
they end up just stepping out of the way
they unlock the door and the Riddler
goes about his business now the other
half of this is the nature of the Joker
himself again because this takes place
after the events of the first zero year
story which dealt with the origin of the
Joker himself this is when he's full-on
in the scene in Gotham and so at this
point people are well aware of who he is
but remember Bruce Wayne has only been
Batman for a very short amount of time
and so that trust between society and
Batman
such as it is has not really been built
up yet the other half of this is that
because they basically figure out the
location of where the Joker is what they
end up doing is basically blowing up his
base of operations just infiltrating the
place trying to take it down only to
realize the Joker's not there the
problem with this and the issue the drug
of the Joker struggles with is that he's
lost his ability to laugh not in the
literal sense it's more of a
metaphorical thing in the sense that the
Joker doesn't really find anything funny
anymore and so the goal is to basically
find something funny now what this does
is it sets the Joker on the path of
looking
Batman is a guy who's basically the butt
of every joke where it basically begins
the process of pitting the two of them
together about how Batman needs the
Joker the Joker needs Batman that kind
of a thing and that's why it's cool is
because at the end of the day the Joker
taking up residence and do whatever it
is he used to do and then ultimately he
and the Riddler encounter one another
and the proposition offered here by the
Riddler is pretty cool for them the idea
of cops being corruptible is a very
simple thing all you have to do is make
enough money to pay off cops and then
those cops are just sorted and that's it
but Batman cannot be bought you know
he's not a person that you can just go
commit crimes and then talk him out of
arresting you it doesn't really work
that way and so because of that the goal
is basically the two of them sitting
down and saying hey look we can make
something that's greater than the sum of
its parts we can literally come together
and we can kill Batman when we do you
get whatever it is you need that will
make you laugh I'll finally topple the
bats and we can just conquer the city
together and just rule it all together
the problem with this is that this feeds
into the unpredictability of the Joker
one of the things that makes the Joker
so dangerous is he is just as likely to
shoot you as he is to work with you and
in this instance Riddler doesn't know
what the Joker is gonna do there's no
predictability there there's no real
pattern there The Riddler says there is
when he basically says look I was able
to figure out you were the one that was
committing all these acts and I figured
out that you can't laugh because you
were basically killing comedians and you
were attacking places you were trying to
find a joke that you could laugh about
and you can find it but I could help you
solve this riddle ultimately the Joker
turns on Riddler actually just shoots
him and then is just done and that's it
the problem with this is that remember
back during this point in his career of
being Batman Bruce Wayne was still very
very new to the whole thing he was still
very unsure of himself in a lot of
different ways he was still figuring it
all out in this instance he believes the
Joker to be more of a credible threat
than the Riddler also because the
Riddler was shot and it looks like he's
just gonna bleed out and die instead
because the fact that Batman goes after
the Joker the Riddler is able to escape
he's able to get away and so is the
Joker and so again that hits home at the
inexperience of Batman the fact that he
doesn't really know what road to taken
so ultimately if this massive war breaks
out between the Joker and the Riddler
where various villains are essentially
forced to take sides now of course the
other half of this is that this also
comes out of the idea of Batman's
conversation with
that woman in the sense because of the
fact that the two of them are supposed
to be getting married to one another the
question is will she actually do it and
is one of those things where Batman's
just kind of dumping his heart out to
the world and telling her everything
about himself his deepest darkest
secrets so that she goes into a marriage
with Batman basically being sure of what
it is she's getting into and that's why
it's cool because at this point we
basically continue to pick up with the
Joker and probably one of his most
ruthless moments now on the surface it
doesn't seem that ruthless it doesn't
seem that hardcore but he actually ends
up walking into a home that currently
belongs to a family that templeton
family walks into their home and the
Joker eliminates them all literally
takes them all out because he's just
trying to find something that's funny
the Riddler ends up coming back by
basically getting some surgical work
done by a disgraced doctor who had long
since lost his career but the other half
of this is the perception that it gives
us of the Joker in relation to how the
rest of the criminal empire views him
when the Joker calls up a guy by the
name of carmine infantino
he basically says look you have an hour
to kill the Riddler and if you don't do
it bad things are gonna happen and
immediately in Patino's on the job it
has his guys taking care of it he
doesn't reluctantly but he ends up doing
it anyway because he knows that the
Joker will follow through with his
scheme this is essentially a scenario
where people are just building up
soldiers to their side when it comes to
the Riddler
teaming up with poison ivy this was
already established in zero year when he
used a lot of the things that she had to
his advantage in order to basically pull
off taking over Gotham a lot of the
traps and different things like that but
when in videos guys run up on Riddler
and poison ivy they're taken out almost
right off the bat and so of course
because of that once again Pitino shows
back up and the Joker sit in his office
and he says and hours passed and the
Riddler's still alive we end up finding
out that the Joker had travelled three
hours to Metropolis to find the mother
of carmine infantino killed her and then
took all of her teeth out of her mouth
that was what he did in response to
Infantino not following his directions
like he said and that's why people are
so terrified of the Joker is because of
the lengths he will go to in order to
pursue his goal that's why he's so
dangerous and so ultimately with Batman
is simply disgusting this whole thing it
turns into just this massive war I mean
on one side you have the Riddler you've
got you know Deathstroke and you got to
face and you have scarecrow and you got
Victor's eyes and all these different
gods and the size of the Joker you've
got Mr Freeze you've got Solomon Grundy
you got the Mad Hatter yeah Deadshot you
have these guys who are basically
criminals that just kind of go about and
they do their own things but all these
different villains that exist in Gotham
City are perfectly aware of the fact
that the Riddler and the Joker are two
of the most dangerous if not the two
most dangerous villains that exist and
so because of that they basically fall
rank-and-file they essentially choose
their sides with whoever it is they
think will ultimately win now the other
half of this is something this does is
it actually switches over to a
completely different guy a guy by the
name of kite man and kite man is the
best character ever I love kite man hell
yeah I love kite man so much but he's
got like this saddest story ever know a
little bit of history here kite man goes
all the way back to 1960 with that man
issue number 133 and he was really more
of just like a joke character that was
created by Bill Finger the idea was a
kite man was like the man who can fly
anything is really what it was and he
would just commit crimes by using
contractions largely associated with
kites and then that would just really be
it he'd become a Batman he'd get beat up
and then he would get thrown in jail or
he would end up getting you know getting
out he played some roles here and there
you know he had involvement like
Infinite Crisis different things like
that but for the most part he was just
this background small-time joke
character in this particular story his
origin is traumatic and he's really this
incredibly interesting character because
the whole idea of the war of jokes and
riddles is not necessarily just the
Joker in in Riddler going to war against
one another it's the people caught in
the middle and there have been a lot of
people caught in the middle of this
whole thing focusing more on the idea of
of Charles Brown the whole purpose of
this is that he's one of these guys who
had previously worked on the Joker
mobile for the Joker so he's got ties to
one of them already and in his
desperation Batman actually snatches him
up subdues him and then sends him in to
essentially spy on the Joker the problem
with this is that him spine is
immediately figured out by the Riddler
because of the fact that they have spies
on both sides I so brought before the
Riddler he basically spills the beans
he's eventually brought before the Joker
who figures out where he basically
explains everything that's going on and
so again it creates kind of a weird
scenario because ultimately when ends up
happening is we basically find out that
because the Riddler
realized that Charles was basically a
spy for Batman who owned to work for the
Joker and had already been taken by the
Riddler ultimately the Riddler had
actually poisoned his son and so the
result is that he basically ends up
losing his son and that's what's so
crazy is because what this does is it
unhinges him he's not Joker crazy he's
basically just sort of lost his mind to
a degree and so what isn't happening is
he actually just kind of takes massive
pieces of fabric starts cutting them out
into the shape of a kite gives himself a
bodysuit and then just starts calling
himself kite man and so as funny as it
is at the end of the day it's basically
this idea that he is a guy who was
really stuck in this crossfire and
experienced one of the worst traumatic
experiences that a parent can ever have
which is losing their child the other
half of this is that will actually find
out there's a lot more going on with the
creation of his character than we
originally thought but with regards to
the major event itself the idea is that
with Commissioner Gordon looking at the
fact that you basically have the Upper
East Side the Upper West Side which have
been taken over by the Joker and the
Riddler the goal is to find a way to
bring the war to an end to basically
preserve Gotham City so nobody else has
to experience a casualty like this the
crazy thing about it is that when Jim
Gordon goes to meet with the Joker when
he goes to meet with the Riddler he's
given demands by both sides in terms of
how he's supposed to show up the Joker
just says show up in your underwear cuz
it's the Joker and when you're the Joker
that's what you do the Riddler is a lot
more complex as his character should be
now the cool thing about this is that
this is designed to display two
diametrically opposed sides and
juxtapose them next to one another the
Joker is simple he's just a crazy guy
who wants to take out Batman that's it
the Riddler is complicated he's
intriguing he's got all this lore and
all this mythology to him the other half
of this is that the war of jokes and
riddles is being fought on a
multi-faceted level you basically have
criminals fighting in the streets of
Gotham City in this instance it's
Deathstroke a genetically modified super
soldier against Deadshot who's just a
super accurate guy but because they're
the two greatest mercenaries in the
world their fight spans five days and 62
people die in the process so it is a
massive calamity between these guys
facing off against one another and it's
a pretty big deal at the end of the day
it all basically comes down to Batman it
comes down to him as a character having
to
figure out a way to end this war knowing
that it's not gonna stop into the Joker
or the Riddler achieve their goal of
essentially taking him out and now the
cool thing about this is that because
Batman has the Wayne family fortune at
his disposal what he actually does is he
orchestrates a sit-down between the
Riddler and the Joker it's basically
just them bickering with each other the
whole time just thinking potshots and
like the Riddler making fun of him and
in that kind of a thing but it's
interesting to see this happen because
it goes down exactly as we would expect
in the sense do they just sort of argue
and carry on different things like that
but it's basically them making the case
as to why it is that they should be the
one to take down Batman and that's the
proposal that Bruce Wayne offers here
again they don't know that Bruce Wayne
is Batman they have no idea that the two
of them are the same person and so going
through and basically pretending as
though he doesn't care about the Batman
concept he doesn't care whether Batman
lizard dies that his loyalty is directly
to Gotham City itself he basically says
both of you guys make your arguments on
who it is you think should win and I'll
give a billion dollars to the winner and
that'll allow them to pay off all the
criminals in Gotham City pay off the
cops do whatever as they need to do in
order to basically take out Batman and
it's kind of crazy because what we end
up finding out is that prior to this
sit-down the Joker and the Riddler had
basically both brought in hostages under
the idea that if something were to
happen to them the hostages would be
killed
what is up happening is the Joker agrees
to free his hostages and the Riddler
believes he killed his before he showed
off which he did it's pretty I mean it's
not funny but it's it's it's pretty it's
messed up me it's pretty messed up I
mean it's kind of rough but but the fact
remains here that it is interesting to
me because again it really hits home
with the notion that Bruce Wayne is
having to do a lot of things that he
never thought he would when it came to
the character of Batman the idea was to
basically be a guy who could essentially
walk the middle ground he could walk the
middle line where he was basically
always doing the right thing he'd have
to make some questionable choices here
and there but there would be the good
guys and the bad guys and the cool thing
about the whole war of jokes and riddles
story so far is that what it shows us is
the length of Batman has to go to from
now on you know to basically be the guy
that could take out the criminals is he
will have to become the antihero who
will have to blur the lines that
sometimes he's going to have to make
questionable choices that will force him
to ask the question am I really a good
guy so that's kind of the crazy thing
about this
one of the major choices that he makes
is he sits down and he says if I have to
pick a winner and if I have to bring
this war to an end and the only way to
stop it is to basically take out one of
these guys then which guy do I side with
he basically makes the smarter choice
and sides with the Riddler because the
Joker is so far gone in a lot of
different ways because he's just so
crazy Batman were to take up sides with
the Joker then the Joker may very well
just kill him at this point you know the
Riddler and the Joker both want to win
so it's really one of those things worse
like the enemy of my enemy is my friend
but there's no guarantee the Joker would
see it that way if the Joker and the
Riddler are at war with one another and
their ultimate goal is to take out
Batman
but in the short term goal is to take
out the other person the Joker may
bypass all that the Joker may say well I
mean the ultimate goal is to take out
Batman so I'm just gonna take him out
and be done and that's it you know and
then whatever happens happens that's the
crazy thing but the Riddler is a lot
more fluid in his thought analytical in
terms of how he looks at things the
Riddler's immediate goal is to take out
the Joker after which then he'll focus
on Batman and so because of that Batman
sides with the Riddler it's just the
smarter choice to make now the other
half of this is also using the resources
of the kite man against both Joker and
Riddler using kites to fly into where
the where the Joker is at and then in
turn in the middle of the whole conflict
once the Joker's temporarily defeated
and the most logical thing happens when
criminals of the Riddler turn against
Batman he basically set things up so
that kite man could modify the packs
kick him into action and they were
basically yanked the criminals out of
Gotham City into the air
would they be swooped up by Alfred in
the bat blimp because apparently the bat
blimp is still a thing but the idea here
is that this ultimately boils down to
the Joker and the Riddler fighting
against Batman but the crazy thing about
this is that this is essentially
everything Bruce Wayne has been talking
about when he's been going through and
recounting this entire story - Selina
Kyle take Catwoman basically saying this
is where I committed the act that I
swore I never would have committed
before we end up finding out that in the
middle of this conflict the only option
Batman feels he has in order to
successfully take out the Riddler is to
kill him and that's exactly what he ends
up doing he harkens back to the idea of
the Riddler killing kite man's son he
harkens back to the idea that this war
has cost so many lives and has seemingly
been pointless and in that anger in that
wrath while he is of clear and sound
mind he takes the action of trying to
kill the Riddler now that's huge for
Batman because it'd be different a
Batman just let himself go right like if
he does
acting out of rage and wasn't thinking
clearly and had a temporary moment of
insanity and once you go tell the
Riddler that would make a lot more sense
for the Batman character in terms of
fans letting it slide I mean Batman fans
will let Batman get away with anything
but in terms of you know people looking
at it and saying okay this is not
something Batman normally should have
done him being of clear and sound mind
shows us how far and how fast he was
able to fly but again it really hits
back home to the nature of the fact that
he's inexperienced because Batman as we
know him now which is to say if you go
crack open a story from DC rebirth and
you read I am Bane or something along
those lines
Batman is calm he's almost in complete
and total control of his faculties and
he never allows himself to get carried
away with wrath or anger and if he does
it's momentary it's never a major thing
in this instance he's still young he's
still reckless allowing himself to get
carried away falls in perfectly with the
idea that he's still trying to figure
out his place in this whole pantheon of
superheroes of the DC Universe in
relation to all the criminals that exist
in Gotham City trying to kill the
Riddler is a pretty big deal because
what is up happening is the Joker
actually gets in his way
and the Joker stops him and in his
insanity finds the whole thing hilarious
but that's what's crazy about it is
because the Joker stopped Batman from
killing the Riddler and that's nuts it's
it's it's wild to really think about it
that way that the Joker was the thing
that kept Batman from falling over the
edge
now this hits home with the nature of
the Joker right like it's a
well-established fact the Joker needs
Batman he needs to have a merry needs to
keep him there and so it makes sense
that he would go that length but
spilling all these beans to Selina Kyle
basically telling her that he allowed
himself to fall to that point where he
almost became the villain that kills
people
he also merely ends up saying look if
we're gonna do this you have to know
what you're getting into I've fallen
before I've made that mistake but Selina
Kyle's argument is everyone has the fact
that you did this all it does is it
makes you human
you get carried away you get angry you
get sad you get filled with emotion just
like anybody else
it's not a failing it's the fact that
you recognize that you fell that makes
you great because it means that you know
where you can get down to and you don't
want to be there anymore and that's why
it's cool is because it's her saying if
you get to that point if you feel
yourself slipping then I will be your
guide I will be the anchor by which I
can pull you from the bottom of this
ocean of despair and I can bring you
to the light and so when the questions
asked will you marry me Selina Kyle says
yes okay so I'll be honest man this
writing regarding Batman and Catwoman it
is it's Dudus it's so cool like it's
it's really amazing you know like what
Tom King is doing it's it's probably the
best thing to come out of DC rebirth so
the whole idea of of that when Batman
and Catwoman it really throws into sharp
relief the nature of like marriages and
comic books right because there's two
types of marriages there's the ones that
are gonna be difficult but interesting
and there's the ones that are too easy
like for example Superman and Wonder
Woman I mean granted super and Wonder
Woman never got married but they were
dating for a while when the new 52 first
kicked off and fans didn't really like
it what story could you write that would
involve Superman and Wonder Woman that
could be compelling and last any real
measure of time Oh No Lex Luthor has
green kryptonite he's attacking Superman
with it you know you know what Wonder
Woman shows up and she knocks out Lex
Luthor and she grabs her green
kryptonite and Chief throws it into
space and Superman gets up and says
thank you Wonder Woman and the story's
over that's it whereas when you have
Superman in like Lois Lane Lois ladies
human she has no powers she's just a
reporter and she's in danger a lot of
the time but she could also hold her own
but the fact that she has no powers
forces the rider to rely on Lois Lane's
ingenuity in order for her to pull it
off and it's cool because with Batman
and Catwoman it's much the same way it
makes sense that Batman and Catwoman
would get together now this whole idea
of Batman marrying Catwoman or at least
proposing to Catwoman does set in stone
this idea that there can be some pretty
compelling stories and this initially
picks off with the two of them just kind
of rolling through the desert and having
to put a horse down because I just can't
walk anymore now it's it's kind of
intriguing because the the interaction
between the two of them in some ways is
almost like an Aaron Sorkin TV show like
an Aaron Sorkin script right like if you
guys ever watch a show like The West
Wing or the newsroom or something like
that the way that Aaron Sorkin writes
interact the interactions between people
people never talk that way but it is
interesting to see and with Batman and
Catwoman it's much the same way you know
where they sort of have these
interactions like they'll finish each
other's sentences or don't know what the
others thinking or something along those
lines and it's almost like a fictional
account of how you imagine a
relationship to be but it works with
these two characters because they've
been enemies for so long but there's
always been this kind of romance between
the two of them and it works and is
really really cool but the other half of
is the bat family right like we talked
about in Red Hood and The Outlaws that
in a lot of ways Jason Todd doesn't see
himself as a tried and true member of
the bat family he is but he doesn't
necessarily see himself that way but in
the middle of the bat family hanging out
doing whatever it is that they do in
their off time I guess hanging out the
library and just you know kicking their
feet up and just talking about stuff
Alfred shows up now Alfred showing up is
always interesting because offers like
the father figure for Bruce Wayne right
and I mean while he is there to serve
the Wayne family keep in mind Bruce
doesn't really treat Alfred like a real
Butler which is to say he's not like
your job is to come here do these things
and then you leave no he's a father
figure
the O Bruce Wayne is almost always
inclined to take the advice of Alfred
unless it runs contrary to what Bruce
Wayne wants to do which is actually
about pretty far from like a father
figure I mean it's actually kind of far
from okay so I don't know how you
reconcile those two things together but
switching back to Batman and to to count
one because again this will bounce back
and forth between those two groups to a
degree we basically pick up with with
the tiger now the tiger is a really
interesting character in fact he was
introduced on in the early days of the
new 52 when DC was experimenting with
the character of Dick Grayson one thing
to remember is that when DC rebooted in
2011 they were switching things up for a
lot of characters a lot of it was
looking at characters who had existed
for a long time and said how can we make
them more intriguing and Dick Grayson
was a really good example of that I mean
you got to think about it Dick Grayson
appeared back in 1939-1940 subtle on
those lines so he was basically Robin
for like 45 years and then eventually he
became like Nightwing becoming Nightwing
having his own story holding his own
character he did that for you know over
20 years and then eventually when DC
rebooted everything in 2011 they made
him a secret agent and while a lot of
people didn't like it it was interesting
because it provided different levels of
storytelling now Tiger was introduced as
like the best spy of spiral which is the
organization that Dick Grayson worked
for but it is kind of cool because it's
always been this theme with its
character that he's the best broker of
information in the world he knows
everything that goes on and so the idea
is that Batman and Catwoman are
searching for a particular person now
from here we jump back to the bat family
and this is really funny it's like a
pretty cool situation because Alfred is
just kind of like alright look Bruce
Wayne left and he wanted missed a legal
mission and there's something that he
did that I'm not supposed to tell you
about but I'm gonna tell you anyway and
everybody's guess is like okay so like
it's gonna destroy the bat family right
because that's usually what happens with
Batman's secrets the big huge revelation
that Alfred drops is Bruce Wayne
proposed to Selina Kyle
catwoman and she said yes and people are
just like what even ace the bat-hound
it's just like what they're like no way
that happened that's crazy talk it's
really funny to see that whole
relationship unfold now forever here
picking back up with Bruce Wayne you
know with Batman and Catwoman they
basically kind of stumble across this
guardian of the desert for the most part
and again we you know it's very
ambiguous here in the beginning it's
kind of like you know what's this
Guardian hiding nobody's supposed to get
in there there's a pact that was struck
between the Justice League and the
United Nations where it was you stay
away we stay away no one goes in there
so it's like whatever's inside this cave
has to be a pretty big deal now the
other half of this and one of the things
that Tom King is really really good at
is messing around with a character of
Catwoman in the sense that a lot of
people view her as like a little girl
like you're here to have fun but you're
way in over your head what a reality
Catwoman's pretty rough around the edges
and this guy probably has about four
feet on her and she beats the crap out
of him it's amazing
it happens off panel but it's pretty
hilarious to see it all take place but
again you know the other half of this is
that of course Alfred gets a response to
the Justice League saying hey look
somebody went with a cave when they were
supposed to and someone so forth and
this kind of tips the bat family off
that somebody needs to intervene or at
the very least needs to show up now of
course with Tiger leading Batman and
Catwoman to this cave it is kind of cool
because basically it's this idea that
Damian Wayne wants to be the person to
go in there Damian Wayne knows exactly
what Batman's looking for and his
response is we have to go and get him
but the fact remains here the person
that Batman searching for inside this
cave is Talia al Ghul the daughter of
Ra's al Ghul now this is a very big deal
because Talia al Ghul is a mother of
Damian Wayne ie the mother of Bruce
Wayne's child and of course it was one
of those scenarios where Bruce Wayne was
kind of duped and then ultimately you
know Talia al Ghul slept with him and
then eventually it led to Damian Wayne
being born about nine months later but
the fact remains here is it's a meeting
of the exes the other half of this as a
Tom King is really really good at
building on the nature of Batman and
Catwoman I mean what did it keep in mind
here you basically got a man who has a
hard time trusting anybody who is
engaged to a woman who's a professional
thief and so it's almost just kind of
like oil and vinegar you would never
expect them to mix but they do and it
works so well the other half of this is
that with Talia al Ghul basically being
told Bruce Wayne has Perez proposed to
Catwoman and he's brought her here it's
almost like a bit of jealousy you know
it's almost like a little bit of whoa
well that's not cool like why would he
bring
here will bring his fiancee here which
it does kind of make sense of course
with regards to like all the guards that
Talia al Ghul Sims after them only they
make pretty pretty quick work of it this
is by no means meant to be a great big
huge point of the story it's just really
designed to show that working together
Batman and Catwoman as a couple are
greater than the sum of its parts which
is to say they're better together than
they are separate this leads to the
arrival of Superman and of course
basically Superman says look Batman is
not supposed to be in there but the
worst thing that we can do is dig a
deeper hole so nobody else is going in
there now in truth this is kind of Tom
Kane's way of basically keeping things
pretty limited if Superman allowed
Damian Wayne to go in well then Superman
will probably have to go in and suddenly
you have this veritable army of people
running into this cave and it would it
would over complicate the story and so
Superman kind of showing up saying look
you can't go in there
of course he takes off to Central City
because of some alien invasion stuff
like that you know and this ultimately
leads to the whole idea of like Damian
and Dick Grayson are considering going
in but of course Dick Grayson chimes in
and says like Superman can still see you
from Central City so he'll be back here
in a heartbeat if he sees you going in
there which is kind of funny you know
and again this is the cool thing is
because the character riding here is
interesting and it's what Tom Kane
doesn't forget about in this scenario
where Damian Wayne's like everybody
wants to kill you using kryptonite I
would use magic but Superman's response
is well I mean you got to thinking about
a Damian if you killed me then Jonathan
wouldn't like you anymore and like
that's enough to stop baby
your friend won't want to hang out with
you anymore now the other half of this
is also the relationship between Dick
Grayson and Damian remember when Damian
first came up him and Dick Grayson
bumped heads and the extreme over the
years of Damian's development starting
in the pre new 52 era going all the way
up to the launch of the new 52 a lot of
it's been the evolution of Damian Wayne
is the evolution of a kid who was raised
in isolation who was raised outside of
tried-and-true human interaction and
being forced to interact with people and
not really knowing how to do it I mean
again kind of the epitome of social
awkwardness I've met a few fans from the
Rob Court who were socially awkward and
they'll tell you man
that is a fly with me decide track here
for a second we've done meetups and
they'll be like fans you just kind of
sit around in the background because
they're nervous and they don't know what
to say and I'm like nope I'm gonna get
you to talk one way or another I'm gonna
get you to talk and I'm gonna answer
your questions on which character is my
favorite superhero and who could beat
who and we'll get ice cream and all
kinds of cool stuff like that I love
hanging out with fans it's one of my
favorites
anyway batman correctly deduces the idea
that these guys showing up and facing
off against him and Catwoman are not to
kill them it's to tire them because
Talia al Ghul finally makes her presence
known and says I challenge the both of
you now in truth she overcomes Batman
pretty quickly and I would surmise
Batman actually lets that happen that
under normal circumstances Batman could
easily take out Talia al Ghul and the
fact that Batman was so easily overtaken
by Talia al Ghul indicates did he let
her overtake him because from there her
focus shifts to Catwoman now I would not
believe that Batman would let Catwoman
die for me I think it's more of a test
where does she reside and that kind of
seems to be how this goes you know with
regards to the way the story ends but
the battle between Catwoman and Talia al
Ghul the battle itself isn't really so
great as much as the dialogue between
the two because one of the things that
happens as Batman says look we're here
for a girl named Holly Kaplan was
accused of killing 237 people she took
the rap for a girl named Holly we're
gonna get Holly to basically confessed
to her crime so they kept one we could
be free and she could marry me without
having to live underground and worry
about the cops chasing her down all the
time to give her some measure of freedom
it's out there but the whole dialogue
between the two is Talia al Ghul starts
to run over this whole scenario where
she says from the time that she could
walk all the way up to the time that she
became the formal a formidable fighter
that she is her father Ra's al Ghul
would throw her sword and say fight and
you keep fighting until I tell you to
stop fighting and if she died he'd throw
into the Lazarus pits resurrector bring
her back out and start the whole process
all over again but the whole scenario
the whole thing that Talia al Ghul is
hitting home is that there's a
difference between the way that Catwoman
lives and the way the world really is
it's a battle of ideologies there's two
kinds of people out there there's people
living their heads in the clouds and
then there's people who understand the
world the way it really is and that's
what this is designed to be Talia al
Ghul is the darker side she's a part
that she believes matches Bruce Wayne
because Batman has the dark side he's
got the brutal side the part that
doesn't really want to let bad guys live
because if they lived and they'll
probably go back to committing their
crimes again it's that side of Bruce
Wayne whereas Catwoman is really kind of
like the caring side the loving side and
that's what's so interesting about this
is because there is this this
conversation that takes place between
Dick Grayson and Damian Wayne Dick
Grayson asks Damian Wayne do you know
why Batman proposed to Catwoman and
Damian Wayne's initial response is I
mean I don't I don't really know I mean
you can offer an opinion but at the end
of the day it's just your opinion and
Dick
as response is because it makes him
happy but the reason why he didn't tell
us is because it means he's asking for
something and that's the coolest thing
is because decreases sistiana he says
look at Batman's history look at
everything that Bruce Wayne does all he
does is give and give and give and give
he sacrifices himself for the betterment
of others it's always been giving things
up it's always been losing things
Batman's never really been able to say
this is mine Batman lost his parents he
lost Jason Todd he lost Alfred for a
time it's always giving things away
losing things were asked with Selina
Kyle Batman's being selfish and he's
earned it
Batman's earned happiness and it's not
easy for Batman to ask for things and
again that's the funny scenario about
this you know because Damian weighs
responses yeah well Batman's happy and
dick races responses know it no he's not
happy he's not happy at all
he's never been happy ever since he lost
his parents he's never been happy it's
always been on the quest to stop crime
but look at everything he's lost in the
process he's never really had any
measure of a long term romantic
relationship his parents have been dead
for years and you'll never get him back
he's lost Robins over the years for
whatever reason he's always lost these
important figures in his life
he's lost friends he's lost superheroes
he's always lost things what he wants is
something to hold on to somebody that he
can have that wants to be there too and
so again it's really interesting because
this is probably the most human analysis
of Batman death there's ever been and
that's why it's so cool that's why it's
so amazing because it's this
philosophical perception that Batman
just wants to be happy
Batman wants to finally come home and he
wants to hang his coat up and say I'm
done and that's what this all really
seems to be about you know Tom King is
knocking on the door of this possibility
that when Batman gets married to Selina
Kyle that a time will come when he will
just walk away from Batman and just say
I'm done now I'll be an adviser I'll pop
into the comics occasionally you know
but from from this point going forward
somebody else will be Batman I doubt
it'll stay that way for any measure of
Todd if it even happens at all I mean I
personally think this is gonna end with
something terrible happening Kevin's
gonna die or something sad like that I
have no idea but you know in my mind it
is beautifully done it's a great
analysis because Batman just wants to be
happy he's just like everybody else he's
tired of fighting he's tired of you know
struggling to hide out giving things up
tired of losing things all the time
he just wants some measure of peace some
small measure of peace and that's why
it's cool because at the end of this
whole battle
sumit Lee Selina Kyle's able to overcome
Talia al Ghul but ultimately Selina Kyle
approaches Holly and of course says look
I'm trying to find happiness myself I'm
trying to get away from this life that
I've been living a thievery and crime
and so on and so forth but I can settle
down with a man that I love and I could
find happiness and I need you to help me
do that by confessing to the crimes you
committed now the other half of this is
Talia al Ghul Talia al Ghul kind of sits
down after the fight with with Catwoman
sits down next to Bruce Wayne is like
look man you didn't make that bad of a
choice she's pretty cool as that's why I
kind of seem to be a test of sorts you
know is this one of those things where
she really is legit now I'm honestly
it's not like Talia al Ghul's word is
law it's just one of those lines is just
kind of thrown out there like hey I mean
you know she's a she's a pretty good
choice but it is kind of interesting in
terms of the whole connection between
the two because Damian Wayne kind of
asked his father you know when Batman
emerges with Catwoman he kind of asked
the father are you happy and so of
course this really hits home with the
idea the Damian Wayne is finally getting
involved into the nature of his father's
role does he care that his father's
happier and happy whatever the case may
be it is interesting and turn to the
evolution of these characters how they
relate to one another
Damian finally beginning to view Batman
as a legitimate father figure instead of
a person who is his father that he just
happens to live with so this story is
like the greatest Batman story ever told
really it's like a Batman Superman story
but it's like the greatest story ever
told I love this story so much now I
mean I haven't read everything about
Batman so I guess maybe it's not I guess
I can't really say it's a greater story
ever told but oh the stories I've read
it's like the best Batman story ever
told
it's so cool because this is all about
like bromance between Batman and
Superman as well as like Catwoman and
Lois Lane okay what would be the woman
equivalent of a bromance like I don't
know what the woman equivalent that is
like oh oh whoa mance I guess I don't
know like maybe there's friends I don't
know like like BFFs I have no idea like
what the what the equivalent of that is
but it is cool because like like
initially this kind of kicks off with
like Superman and in Lois Lane kind of
going back and forth right and the whole
reason why is because Lois Lane is like
you should call Batman like we need to
hang out like we do like get together
and like we need to like hang out and
have some fun and just like have like an
adult's night out because like it would
be fun and it's kind of funny because
like Superman avoids it right he's just
kind of like oh I'm busy you know I've
got I've got stuff you know that I've
got to do I mean I've got you know
superhero things like it's just making
up reasons for why you can't call Batman
and the
I'm Batman does the same thing right I
mean Catwoman and Batman are facing off
against some guys you know and it's like
well you should call Superman like like
you know he's like the best friend you
have like we need to hang out we got to
get together and that's what's kind of
funny about this is like when it comes
to the way these stories are done you
have like Lois Lane and Catwoman who
kind of stand in as the voice of reason
and we wouldn't normally expect it to be
that way right like we've been expected
to be like Batman and Superman who were
like the voices of reason but are there
like two guys who just can't bring
themselves to call each other because
it's all kind of based on Pride and all
that kind of stuff but as this goes on
it kind of begins to sort of Windell
things down to where we get to like the
heart of the matter of why they won't
necessarily call each other I mean Lois
Lane wants to meet Catwoman and like
Catwoman wants to meet Lois Lane and so
really to kind of like bring the two
together sort of going through their
husbands it's really funny you know
because when it comes to like Lois Lane
she just dances look you know I've
looked at me Catwoman you know I've
looked into what she's about you know
I've looked into who she is as a villain
basically like Selina Kyle and I'm I'm
curious about her like I want to know
what would lead a person to want to
marry Batman I want to know what level
of insanity would drive a person to that
cloth how do you to know why this is the
case and again it is fun because we
would kind of expect them you know
Superman is gonna be like okay cool
let's let's call let's see what's up
like listen let's get together but once
we start to go through into these little
Nick's and crannies you leave these
little tidbits these little small things
it's sort of make these characters who
they are what we end up finding out is
like Batman and Superman in a lot of
ways idolize each other like I mean you
got Superman fighting against some
radiation guy you know I don't really
know his name I don't really care enough
to look it up but you got Superman
fighting some radiation guy you've got
Batman going against this various group
you know and really these roads are kind
of leaving them to each other but it's
not really the villains they're facing
it's not that's not the important part
of this the important part of this is
that they sort of hide light the other's
existence they highlight the other's
purpose the role they play they
highlight who they are and what they're
about when it comes to Batman he sits
down and he simply says boy at least
would count woman speculates it says
you're ashamed of me of course Batman's
response is of course not that's crazy
talk I am not ashamed of you at all that
would land me in the dog house if I said
yes even if I was joking but still from
Batman's perspective the almost see
Superman is like a better man than him
and that's what's so interesting about
this but at the same time Superman sees
Batman as a better man than him each one
puts the other on a pedestal and that's
what's so why this was so cool about
this because all they really see are
like the great aspects of each other now
just a hallmark of having a friendship
it stood the test of time for so long I
mean that's really kind of the thing
that goes into all this is that you've
got Superman and Batman who were like
the one-two punch of DC Comics and
they've been neato they've been enemies
they've been friends all those things
but all that has kind of built up over
the years into this tried and true
friendship that's had its ups and downs
but each one respects the other to such
a degree that they don't really see the
flaws and the other person I mean they
know they're there
but they don't really look at those
aspects they look at what makes them
great Batman is is the detective he's
like one of the smartest men if not the
smartest man I would argue that maybe
Lex Luthor is a little bit smarter
depending on what circumstance were
talking about but by and large like mr.
terrific Batman Lex Luthor had like the
top three spots but still in the eyes of
Batman Superman is like the hero he's
the good guy like he's the boy scout and
even if Batman will give him a hard time
over it there's respect found in that
there's respect found in the idea that
Superman will put all others above
himself and Batman will too but where
Batman is kind of like the dark and
brooding side of role really of like a
singular person Superman is kind of like
the uplifting side that's the cool thing
about this you juxtapose these people
you put them into like one person and
suddenly like they're just two sides of
any one individual person they keep each
other balanced and they keep each other
grounded and so what is up happening is
that the villains a face basically leads
into like one particular building and
they take two different Everett
entrances to get in there Batman sneaks
in because you know he's Batman like
that's what you do when you're Batman
you don't just walk in the front door
that's crazy talk if Batman we're gonna
go grocery shopping for example Batman
would not go to like you know Kroger's
and like walk in the front door he would
like jump on top of the building and
like sneak down feel like the ductwork
and then like sneak around and get what
he wants and then like swipe his bat
credit card and be out before anybody
knows he's there but like when you're
Superman you know like yeah man we gotta
go grocery shopping because we're low on
lettuce you know and like you you go in
there and you buy the stuff you need and
then you leave like a normal human being
does but still like they end up running
into each other and it is kind of funny
because what ends up happening is like
they're kind of standoffish right like
well I didn't expect to see you here
Batman
you know and maybe have like Selina Kyle
and Lois Lane and Lois Lane's like you
must be Catwoman
it's nice to meet you and like they
immediately break the ice and start
shaking hands now of course these
villains show up and of course they make
quick work out of them but Superman's
response is well let's get some dinner
this is
the story gets amazeballs it gets so
cool they show up to the Gotham County
Fair and it's superhero night no I want
to be honest with you guys I've been
doing a lot of fairs all right I've been
to a lot of fairs a lot of carnivals in
my time I have never seen a carnival or
Fair where it's like you can't get in
here unless you're dressed as a
superhero I really want to go to one of
these anyway when these guys get in here
it's kind of funny because they're
immediately turned away right they're
like hey look it's superhero night you
have to be a superhero if you're not
dressed as a superhero you can't come in
here and they don't believe they're
superheroes even though this guy is
talking to Batman and Superman Lois Lane
and Catwoman have this genius idea
whether like well let's just switch
costumes Batman can be Superman and
Superman can be Batman and like AI Lois
Lane will be like like Catwoman and it's
like the most beast idea ever right
because like the whole time Batman's
like no we're not doing this we're not
we're not doing this all right we're not
switching into costumes we're not
trading places we're not doing any of
this stuff we're gonna sit and be sad
because like I'm Batman that's what I do
I mope and so like you guys know it
Batman mopes but still like the funny
thing is that we're we're Batman's
adverse to it all Catwoman's like whoa
you guys misunderstand what he's saying
when he says no when he says no what he
means is that he knows his fiancee is
really hungry and she's being very
patient right now
but her patience is running out very
very fast and he recognizes he needs to
remedy that and so he's going to do that
aren't you Batman because it's in your
best interest to do that and so like
they do as any married man will tell you
if the wife ain't happy ain't nobody
happy and so it's funny because like
they basically switch costumes and like
the whole time this happens it looks so
amazing like it's so cool because you've
got Batman who's cheery and Superman
who's just like mopey you know like like
I'm just gonna call the Batman suit
right now I'm gonna confuse the heck out
of you guys but you got like Bruce Wayne
Superman who's just like this is not
going to be fun but I mean look at this
it's like the most fun ever like you're
eating corndogs and like Lobo is doing
the Hammer machine thing that like like
people always fail out and they feel bad
I mean it's cool with this thing because
I did go into the tunnel of love and
it's like it's like a married couple
versus a a newlywed couple Clark Kent
and Lois Lane come out it's this is so
weird to me like seeing them like this
Clark Kent and Lois Lane come out
they're like well that was nice man
Bruce Wayne - Selina Kyle come out and
they're just they're going at it like
rabbits and he it is it
amazing but the best part of this is the
batting cage right when they get to the
batting cage they're just like smacking
baseball's left and right and then
Superman's like hey man I mean I could
pitch to you if you want like you
wouldn't hit it but I mean I could pitch
to you if you want and then Batman's
like naw dude like if you pitch to me
Superman I would smash that baseball
like you don't have a chance like
there's really nothing you could do here
like I would absolutely smash I think
something else also want you guys to
notice too Superman is dressed as Batman
wearing his glasses I think it's
hilarious
I think it's amazing Batman wearing
glasses Batman weren't specs to that
this is this is like the most fun I've
ever had covering a story before this is
amazing but the other half of this is
like like we pick up with Lois Lane and
Catwoman right and this is this is this
is cool because for the most part again
like they're foreign entities to each
other to a degree and the biggest
question that the Lois Lane has is like
why Batman like of all the people you
could marry why would you marry Batman
and the answer of Catwoman is so simple
and it's so amazing and it's beautifully
done her response is it's just because
he catches me when I fall and as
innocent oh the question is like like
can you relate to that and it's it's so
cool because like that's the story of
Superman and Lois Lane and we've said it
a million times before Lois Lane Falls
Superman catches her but it's that he's
always there for her and she's always
there for him it is the definition of
what it means to be like a tried and
true partner you know try to Dru luck I
mean that's kind of the nature of life
right I mean when people get together
and people get in relationships they're
not really waiting on Superman right I
mean like like a lot of women out there
are really waiting on Superman to show
up and whisk them away from all the
dangers of the world and to give them
all the money they need so they never
have to worry about things I mean there
are some who are but like by and large
if a woman out there is waiting on
Superman is because she's superwoman
she's looking for a partner she's not
looking for a superhero white knight to
show up and rescue her from all of
life's struggles you know the the idea
of a relationship is coming across
problems and solving them together and
that's why this works is because the
relationship between Selina Kyle in
Batman is juxtaposed right next to the
relationship between Lois Lane and
Superman and where we would think they
would be starkly different and where we
would think it would all be predicated
on two completely diametrically opposed
views instead they're the exact same
everybody's looking for the same thing
everyone is looking for love and we're
Lois Lane and Superman fan
selina kyle and batman have found it but
it's one of those things were like when
you cut below the personality of Gotham
when you cut below the hole you know I'm
putting this wall up because I'm Batman
and this walls here because I protect
myself from the world when you cut past
all that and when you cut past you know
Selina Kyle he does the same thing there
does to people looking for love and they
found it in each other and that's why
this is so beautiful and that's why this
is so cool
now from here like it's kind of funny
because as they're walking along this
guy dresses the question runs up and
snatches the purse of Lois Lane and it's
hilarious because it's like the question
is that who's going to let me the
question is who is going to stop me and
it's this is hilarious honestly if I saw
this like if I were at like this
superhero themed comic book him or
another yeah I guess like a comic book
convention at a theme park like if I
were there and I saw this I would try to
get it like I would try to record it and
like I would upload it as a front bumper
on my channel I'd be like guys you have
to see this you know and they're like I
would put it in the video but like
people would love it and it would be
amazing and I would just be like yes yes
all those likes I am feasting on them
but like it would be it'd be hilarious
because in response to all this Superman
and Batman are just kind of watching
this happen and then like like
Superman's like okay so like here's how
far this guy is how fast he's traveling
and Batman's like god it throws a
baseball knocks the dude right out and
somebody dresses Green Lantern is just
kind of like damn also maybe it's just
me that guy looks like he's dressed as
Alan Scott Green Lantern oh my god
they're reversing Alan Scott Green
Lantern like the old Alan Scott now the
new Alan Scott the new Alan Scott's not
as good as you old one the old Alan
Scott but once that eye starts to wind
down like once everything starts to come
to a close and it really starts to come
to an end it's really more or less
everybody just saying hey look this was
amazing like this was this was a great
time you know I had a blast Batman is
just kind of like no I did not have fun
even though I did I'm just not going to
tell you like I mean that's that's
brooding Batman but you know when the
whole thing winds down is funny because
the Superman's like hey man like I'd
still love to like pitch at you sometime
to like throw a baseball and see if you
can hit it you know I mean you can't but
like I mean we'll see what's up it was
like I know a place so they end up at
like a baseball pitch right and this
this is a cool this is a coolest thing
ever
we end up at a baseball pitch and like
Superman goes to throw the baseball and
Batman's like dude um I'm gonna hit it I
mean that's just the way it is you know
and Superman is like whatever man nobody
can hit this baseball like you're not
gonna hit this baseball Batman and
Superman throws the ball and he's like
here's to the impossible and in the
comic games we never find out what
happens that's not true I don't know why
I told you that what is
- his Batman smashes it why because he
has prep time okay so we are picking up
with actually what I think is one of the
coolest stories in DC we were so far
with Batman which is called the gift and
this actually sees the return of Booster
Gold now Booster Gold also did appear in
the booster shot with Superman but we
haven't really covered that yet that
actually comes in the aftermath of the
Oz effect so I will probably cover that
sometime in the next couple weeks or so
but when it comes to like this that this
is really I think this does a better job
of kind of hitting home at the nature of
Booster Gold really feel like a lot of
new fans and the reason why is because
for people who are getting into DC
rebirth are really getting into DC
Comics because of DC rebirth there's a
very good chance you have no idea who
Booster Gold
is now he was in like new 52 and you did
see him there but really a lot of fans
modeling's how they think of Booster
Gold really comes from like before the
new 52 right like it comes with the
post-crisis landscape and the reason why
was because that was when Booster Gold
really blew out I mean Booster Gold was
introduced in 1986 so he's a post-crisis
character but the idea here is that when
DC when you had the original Justice
League back in breda back in not braving
the bolt and then they got their own
solo series you know really for my 1960
going forward when crisis on Infinite
Earths happened
DC canceled the Justice League in its
entirety they got rid of the traditional
Justice League team Batman Superman
Wonder Woman Green Lantern all that kind
of gets stuff to flash and they
relaunched it under Keith Giffen and JM
DeMatteis
as Justice League International and the
reason for this was because by the time
crisis on Infinite Earths happened the
core members of the Justice League were
hugely popular I mean they didn't really
need a Justice League team it was cool
to have but the concept of the team
could be used for other purposes namely
bolstering of popularity of characters
who just really couldn't sell their own
bucks because the name Justice League
was so huge and so handing it over to to
given and Mateus and then having them
revamp it as Justice League
International meant the name remain the
same but the roster changed now of
course in order to keep weary readers
from walking away in its entirety
they threw batman on his leader of the
team and that was enough to keep people
you know keep you all interested and
then once you know the the roster began
to take form and you had like guy
gardner and he had Booster Gold and he
had Blue Beetle the kind of comedy /
serious nature of the stories proved to
be hugely popular Justice League
International was massive when it first
showed up people loved it now as time
progressed it began like people began to
lose edge
and that's the reason why in 1998 uh
Justice League International was just
basically wiped away all the Justice
League teams were removed in their
entirety and then you got JLA by Grant
Morrison Justice League of America it
was the return of the original Justice
League team but nonetheless when it came
to the character of Booster Gold he was
really popular because one he was a
glory hound and two like he was
basically a crook he was he was a guy
from the future who had used his
knowledge of of current events because
he was from the future and showed up and
then it was just like I know how to save
everything and it was funny for what it
was but it was really more the
relationship between Blue Beetle and Ted
Kord that helped to make Booster Gold
hugely popular like that's really really
what kind of set things off this sort of
like you know buddy-cop duo that the two
of them formed made them wildly popular
for a lot of fans and so really liked
that aspect of Blue Beetle always almost
always remained there were a lot of
great stories that dealt with the idea
that he felt like he had the weight of
the world on his shoulders
but for the most part he was just kind
of like that comedic element and so he
always had that that little bit of humor
here so what this story does is it
initially does not pick up with Booster
Gold
instead it picks up with Green Lantern
it picks up with Hal Jordan and he
basically offs himself which is actually
kind of wild because it's like like
right off the bat I mean one he's kind
of grinning it looks pretty sadistic and
screwed up but two he's just kind of
like look the Rings don't let you take
and take yourself out but if you
overcome the willpower of the ring like
you can do whatever you want to do and
like death falls in line like we know
that from the Green Lantern mythos now
of course we end up finding out he does
this in the face of Booster Gold but
this is kind of crazy because everything
is screwed up right now and it's kind of
wild because it's like what in the world
is going on and so ultimately you end up
having Blue Beetle who's just kind of
like okay look you know we got to go
find Batman you know we got to go find
Batman and we have to show um you know
everything that's going on what have you
and then of course he's taken out from
behind by Batman but Batman's Batman's
wearing guns and so right off the bat
the idea that Batman is strapped with
like massive bullets he's got grenades
he's got you know these huge guns he
looks like Arnold Schwarzenegger from
Terminator blended with cable from
Marvel Comics which is actually pretty
cool he looks like The Punisher can we
all just admit here that if Batman
became the Punisher it would probably be
the coolest thing ever like that's a
story we need to have but basically it's
this idea that is almost reminiscent a
flashpoint when you have the flashpoint
event anyway we got this alternate
reality we had a surge a circumstance
where Bruce Wayne died instead of his
parents and Thomas Wayne became Batman
and Martha Wayne became the Joker it was
an amazing story when it came out it was
like what is a a to maybe there's like a
three or four part story I think was for
but with this thing it's cool because
this version of Batman is just like
ruthless and it's very reminiscent of
how Thomas Wayne was Thomas Wayne was
cutthroat he would kill people he would
do whatever he had to do but while you
end up having like Booster Gold and
Batman who were facing off against one
another we transition over to Jason Todd
and what we end up finding out here is
Jason Todd is not the Red Hood instead
what's been going on here is Jason Todd
is actually like he owns a tire company
and this tire company specializes in
basically creating tires that shock
Joker's from stealing people's stealing
people's rims basically now again this
is cool because this is blending a lot
of small things together right like I
mean if you if you look at DC like have
you been reading DC for a while then
like it's taking all these little
threads all these little tidbits and
sort of bringing them all together for
example the concept of the Joker's
definitely comes from Batman Beyond and
Batman Beyond the Joker had long since
been dead and in his place came like the
Joker game and so you had like all these
people men and women who would dress up
as Joker's and then go out and commit
crimes also notice here that it's
basically Joker with like a rod in his
hand which is kind of like a throwback
basically to like the the death death
and the family story arc where Jason
Todd originally died in DC Comics but
this is kind of cool because what this
indicates here is that of course Jason
Todd never became Red Hood which
indicates that Jason Todd was never
adopted by Batman if that wasn't the
case then we don't really know where he
ends up coming from instead we just know
he kind of becomes a tire mechanic the
other half of this is Booster Gold
talking to his machine
Skeets now Skeets is the means by which
Booster Gold travels back and forth
through time and will actually get a
little bit of clarification on that here
in a minute so we won't spoil it for
right here and now but though the thing
that I want you guys to notice here is
really the relationship between the two
of them because this was a hallmark of
Booster Gold the fact that he and his
machine would bicker with each other
Booster Gold was always a character who
seemed kind of childish and when taken
out of context and and really when when
sort of just thrown out there by himself
it can be hit and miss in a lot of ways
he can be like Deadpool I think the
success of Booster Gold really comes
into play when someone takes his
character and they throw it into a comic
where he has someone to bounce off of
and that's why Booster Gold will always
worked so well because in a lot of ways
the relationship between like Booster
Gold and and Blue Beetle or like Booster
Gold and Batman or even Superman is very
much akin to like cable and Deadpool
they just kind of bounce off each other
it's serious combined with like humor
now Brewster Gold's taken by Batman kind
of whisked away and it's kind of like
hung from from a balcony and that's when
you end up finding out this Batman is
actually Dick Grayson no again this is
what
the things that I love about stories
like this is because we're not gonna
find out how Dick Grayson became Batman
and that's why things like this are so
cool why the mini series of like like
white knight and and things like Knight
wings new order the reason why those
little things and tidbits like this are
so cool is because they keep us wanting
more and that's actually a genius move
to kind of sidetrack here for a second
one of the big issues that Marvel's been
struggling with for the last while is
they've really kind of reverted back to
where DC used to be maybe 50 or 60 years
ago in the sense of they're like very
very linear stories and Marvel is like
that when Stan Lee and Jack Kirby were
writing stories but they're very linear
stories it's just kind of like you know
here's an event that sets off this story
and then here's a story happening and
then the story ends done and like that's
it it doesn't really give you any reason
to want anything more than what you
already see but with stories like this
the reason why these are a great
reprieve is because you're just kind of
like well then how in the hell did Dick
Grayson become Batman where's Bruce
Wayne like what's going on with Bruce
Wayne's character like those are the
kind of things that you want to know and
they keep us coming back and they keep
us wanting more and then we end up
tweeting the hell out of the writer give
us the answer to this question give us a
one shot man like do something that's
where we could we kind of get a real
cool interest with those things now
again the other thing to bear in mind
here is that when Booster Gold makes his
escape one thing to remember is that
while he is a glory hog and while he is
somewhat nonsensical he is not incapable
Booster Gold is very much a capable
superhero in a wide variety of different
ways what we also end up doing here and
this is really more of us of an aside
than anything else we actually pick up
with Duke Thomas and this is kind of
interesting here I think this was really
done just for the purpose of showing
where Duke is in and what Dukes doing
but he hasn't really had that many
significant roles in DC Comics that
there's a reason for fans to care about
what's going on with him here but again
it is kind of a cool thing to see I mean
at this point Duke Thomas is basically
had his head cut open he's been
lobotomized and someone's just kind of
screwed feeding him and that's it but
the fact remains here what we end up
doing is switching over to Bruce Wayne
and that's when we find out in this line
and this in this current set of
circumstances Bruce Wayne ever became
Batman and the reason why Bruce Wayne
ever became Batman is because Bruce
Wayne's parents never died Thomas and
Martha Wayne are still very much alive
and Booster Gold
shows up and he's like hey man like I
got a present for you what I did is I
went back in time and I saved your
parents from dying and so like your
parents are alive now because of what
I've done but I did that because you're
getting married and I wanted you to see
what happiness would be like so like now
we have to go back and we have to like
let your parents die it's kind of
screwed up
it's kind of messed up my hey man this
life you're living is a lie but this is
the gift that I gave you and now I'm
gonna take this gift and take it away
it's like giving a person a million
dollars and just saying I wanted you to
see what it was like to hold a million
bucks thanks and then just take the
million dollars and leave but like
that's Booster Gold
now the funny thing about this is the
responsive Bruce Wayne is like I've
always known that that was the case I've
always had this itch under my skin
there's always just like this phrase on
the edge of my tongue I knew that
something wasn't right here it was an
itch that I couldn't scratch things are
not the way they're supposed to be and
so the result is that he's like okay I
mean I guess things could go back to
normal but I don't want them to so he
destroys Skeets strapped you know Travis
Booster Gold on them in the modern day
and leaves him there and then just
leaves and goes back to his life and we
pick up a year later and then we end up
having Booster Gold who breaks into
Arkham Asylum to free Catwoman and so
picking up with with Thomas and Bruce
it's kind of cool here but we also in
defining out some somewhat seedy things
are going on of course you know Oswald
Cobblepot the penguin basically is
President of the United States but still
like Thomas has done some seedy things
and that's the interesting thing about
this is when you go through and you look
at the various iterations of Thomas
Wayne and DC Comics and even when you go
back and you look at like the origin of
Batman the indication is that Thomas
Wayne was always a good guy know along
it was because we didn't get a whole lot
about him and it's only really in like
expanded flashbacks well just to say
flashback to give you more information
about his dad that there seems to be the
possibility that maybe he did some seedy
things that maybe he wasn't really as
legit as we thought he was but still
like in this he's been working to try to
make Gotham a better place but there's
just kind of something off about him but
in the midst of all this because of the
fact that everything's crashing down
because villains are going awry because
everything is going crazy here what we
end up having is one he suffers a heart
attack and - the revelation is that like
Oswald Cobblepot is gonna bring in the
forces of Ra's al Ghul who have
basically conquered Europe and Asia
combine them into a single continent and
then use those forces to essentially
quell any kind of rebel threat that
exists inside the United States but the
hidden letters here the hidden wording
the invisible ink really kind of says
that like Ra's al Ghul like once he gets
in he will not leave and so he'll get
his forces in here and then he could
potentially conquer the United States
not only that of course pick Nia with
Booster Gold he's really kind of
rambling on - Selina Kyle but we start
learning some things that are going on
behind the scenes that when Booster Gold
travelled back in time and stopped the
parents of Bruce Wayne from dying that
of course that meant Bruce Wayne never
became Batman
and because Bruce Wayne never became
Batman Bruce Wayne never joined the
Justice League and because Bruce Wayne
never joined the Justice League that
meant that there was no one there to
save the Justice League when they first
faced off against star up and when that
happened
Starro killed two Justice League they're
all dead and so it's kind of crazy
I mean you end up having like you know
um you know Green Lantern of course he
was alive but like the the indication
seems to be here Wonder Woman presumably
Martian Manhunter
ah the flash they're all dead but again
this is one of those things we're just
like well I mean I like I want to see
him I want to see this climactic battle
and I want to see how I want to see how
they died like those are the kind of
things that are kind of interesting
because I'll be honest with you guys if
there's a story where like the Justice
League dies or like a superhero team
that I really love and there's like this
dystopian future where everything goes
bad and they die like I want to see how
it happens like I wanted to OS I want to
see that take place but booster gold's
idea is okay we have to take you captain
we have to get you to Bruce Wayne
because Bruce Wayne's gonna marry you
and and if we get you to him then
everything will be fixed and everything
will be fine and the two of you will get
married and so his line of logic is I'll
take you to Bruce Wayne and everything
will be sorted out and so of course
picking up with Bruce and Martha this is
actually one of those instances when you
see a harder side of Martha that you
never really seek more there's always
kind of given to us is like this tender
person of course it's kind of funny
because she puts on this hard edge but
the doctor comes out and says if you'll
come with me and she's like well what
about my husband he's like well I need
you to follow me in her immediate
responses we are Wayne's of Gotham City
we not follow anybody you tell me what I
want to know not now but right now and
it's cool because it's just like BAM
Martha Wayne just boom just like that
and I like that I like seeing that hard
gritty edge of Martha Wayne because it's
like a side you never really see and
it's kind of a way to say look like the
Wayne's are still very powerful in the
city of Gotham they're still like
probably the number one family in Gotham
City they're a very big name and so
again we end up finding out that Thomas
survived the experience he's not dead
but then from there you basically end up
picking up with like booster and in in
Catwoman travelling to the house of
really to like Wayne Manor to pick up
with with Thomas and Martha and Bruce
the problem with this is that Booster
Gold is only ever paying half attention
to what's going on and he doesn't
realize the reason why Catwoman was in
Arkham Asylum is it because she's just
like an incorrigible robber or anything
like that it's because she's an insane
serial killer and so as soon as she gets
into Wayne Manor
she starts killing everybody Alfred's
the first one to fall which is always
the case guys riders can we please stop
killing Alfred I love Alfred alright
please
kela my main man Alfred Catwoman goes
through there and she literally just
starts tearing people up and just starts
like taking everybody out
now of course Batman's follow them there
and what this does is it turns into like
a bloodbath I mean this is a massacre
Batman goes after Booster Gold and
Catwoman Catwoman goes after Bruce Wayne
and Anne Thomas and Martha Wayne and she
kills them all like Alfred like Catwoman
kills Alfred shoe killer kills Thomas
she kills Martha she kills Batman she
kills them all except for Booster Gold
but then you end up having Bruce Wayne
who gets the shot off on Catwoman and so
Booster Gold unconscious and everyone
else is dead and it's just like Jesus
like this is insane
Tom King the Tong King knows how to ride
a donkey knows how to ride a quite crazy
stuff it's it's but it's cool though
because from there you basically pick up
with this this this idea that Batman or
I guess Bruce Wayne is now completely
and totally resolved and what he's
actually doing is taking shots at Batman
and taking shots at Catwoman by various
statues that he's created and honing his
skills but this is really Tom Kings way
or seems to be tom keys way of saying
that like Bruce Wayne does not have the
various skills with weapons use and
things like that that we would expect
he's literally like learning how to
shoot here and it works for what it is
and the reason why is because it fits in
perfectly with the way the stories being
told that with Bruce Wayne having never
lost his parents he never had a reason
to become Batman which meant he never
had a reason to learn all that kind of
stuff and so because he never had a
reason he's basically learning those
things now and so he's not as capable as
we would expect him to be but he's also
got Booster Gold just kind of chained up
inside this giant cave and that's really
about it he's just kind of keeping in
there and so what he ends up doing is
having guys basically clean up Booster
Gold they fix Skeets and the response is
you're gonna take us back in time and
you're gonna take us back to the to the
point where my parents died and we're
gonna fix it now here's the funny thing
about this is the time machine of
Booster Gold is not an absolute thing
you just kind of have to say like send
us back to like about this general point
in time like send us back to this point
where I did a thing like that's that's
how his time machine works I said where
Bruce Wayne kind of offers out it orally
says that's how Booster Gold puts off
the reception this time machine works
and so we're Batman we're Bruce Wayne's
kinda like okay look fine then like take
us back ten minutes before my parents
died then you in turn have Booster Gold
he's like okay we can do that now this
is what this is one of the funnier
moments in the comics because then like
as that happens he just kind of like
he's like yeah he's like he's like
Skeets do that
send us 10 minutes before Bruce Wayne's
parents died and then winks and so like
you get this hilarious exchange because
he's just like Bruce Wayne he's like
like what did you just wait why did you
wink and it just kinda like this going
back and forth like what what do you
mean like I mean I didn't I didn't wink
so I guess you did it's like well I mean
I winked but there was a fly in my eye
there was no fly they're like it's it's
funny to see these this is this going
back and forth this is a moment when I
say that Booster Gold works really well
when he has someone to bounce off of
like this from there like like you end
up having them basically jump back ten
minutes before and then we end up
finding out it's not 10 minutes before
the massacre in Wayne Manor it's 10
minutes before Booster Gold basically
saved the parents of Bruce Wayne when he
was a kid
and that's kind of a tragic thing here
is because Booster Gold kind of has to
make this choice right um he's kind of
like look basically I just have to buy
time he's got to kill 10 minutes but
he's not telling he's not telling Bruce
that Bruce has no idea where they are
right now all he knows is that they're
on a rooftop somewhere he doesn't know
exactly I mean he could kind of look
around the skyline and get a pretty good
idea of where they're located at but
like witnessed time passing suddenly you
have Booster Gold when he originally
showed up here and so you got two
boosters fighting at the same time and
so of course he shows up the intention
is to basically save the pairs of Bruce
Wayne but instead Thomas Wayne I'm sorry
Bruce responds exactly as you would
expect he takes out that version of
Booster Gold and so from there it's like
okay now we basically have to like let
this let these events unfold you end up
having like the original Booster Gold
facing off against Booster Gold as he
I'm sorry facing off against Bruce Wayne
alongside Booster Gold as he exists now
and all the while where this fights
taking place you have Thomas and Martha
who hear the gunshots of like Bruce
Wayne when he's facing off against these
two boosters and the response is well
things are kind of weird so like let's
go this way instead and they run into
Joe Chill Joe Chill that whole
circumstance unfolds exactly if you
would expect it to Thomas and Martha
Wayne are dead and this is kind of crazy
because it's basically Tom Kane's way of
saying like Bruce Wayne kind of
engineered the death of his own parents
Bruce Wayne basically this kind of has
to look down and realize that his
parents are dead
that like there's no way to escape this
and so ultimately Bruce Wayne turns a
gun on himself and and that's the end of
that and someone turn like Booster Gold
basically fix things and so of course
Booster Gold jumps back everything sets
back to the way it was supposed to be
and then of course Bruce Wayne or I'm
sorry Booster Gold reveals everything to
Bruce and says hey look here's what I
did and here's how I screwed up and and
so on and so forth but it's kind of cool
here because this is designed to do two
things
when you expect and one you don't expect
the one you expect is it basically just
kind of shows Booster Gold despite his
best intentions usually ends up screwing
things up Booster Gold tries to do the
right thing and ends up doing all the
wrong things instead but to me and I
think I don't know if this was Tom Kings
intention but to me this clarifies the
events of Flashpoint and what dr.
Manhattan did
at the outset people will look at this
and they will say okay how can booster
gold travel back in time and allow Bruce
Wayne's parents to survive and then
travel back in time again and allow them
to die and things go right back to the
way they were before
like flashpoint showed us if you go into
the past and you screw things up like
you'll change the future but when you go
into the past and you try to fix them
the future will still be different
originally like from the from the way it
was supposed to go because the very fact
that you traveled into the past changed
how the future is gonna turn out like
you you've altered the course of the
future so you can never make it exactly
the way we were supposed to be you've
altered the direction things are gonna
go alright here's why I think this works
if you look at flashpoint for the way it
was originally written that logic is
sound the way that you think about that
is 100% correct
it is absolutely accurate but what DC we
worth has said is that when Barry Allen
went into the past and saved his mom's
life and then initiated the flashpoint
universe and then went back in time
after realizing that his mom has to die
things were supposed to go back to
normal
nothing was supposed to change but dr.
Manhattan changed it and so this fits in
perfectly with that because what it
basically says is like that can happen
someone can go into the past they can
change things realize that what they
changed was wrong go back to the past
again to set them back to rights and
everything will be okay everything will
be fine
it's the fact that dr. Manhattan changed
things due to flashpoint that's what
really throws that throws a wrench in
the works
that's why everything seems so different
now than the way it was originally
supposed to be before cooler before new
52 happen before the events of
Flashpoint took place so I wanted to
throw that out there because to me it
kind of it works I think it works really
really well I think it actually fits in
perfectly I think that was probably one
of the reasons why Tom Kane may have
done it like this is so that in future
stories when the whole DC thing gets
lined out we get that huge explanation
from dr. Manhattan about what he did why
he did it and so on and so forth and
even if things don't go back to normal
this will fit in very nicely with that
it'll fit in nice and snug with
everything that's been done so far and
it won't really stand out and it won't
really you know be out of place but
without being said guys we're gonna go
and bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained to
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you